zur verfügung ich glaube es besteht
keine notwendigkeit irgendwelche lange
vor worte zu sprechen das thema ist
allen bekannt da die geschäfte bietet
cyber stabilität regionale konflikte was
handelsbeziehungen
wir haben auch über die zusammenarbeit
in der axis gesprochen bitte stellen sie
ihre fragen
einen schönen abend
vielleicht können sie uns das mitteilen
welche den besonders ausführlich
besprochen werden zum beispiel
interessiert uns die ukrainische
kontexte ob die probleme sind dann
passt's besprochen worden oder denn die
möglichkeit des beitritts zur nato der
ukraine und auch zb andere frage ob
bestimmte wii verhältnisse sind die
verhandlungen
was die rückkehr der botschaft der
angeht an deren arbeitsstellen
beziehungsweise nach moskau und den
amerikanischen botschafter und den
russischen botschafter nach washington
wir haben das beschlossen die
botschafter kommen zurück dann wären sie
und stelle waren das genau passiert
morgen oder übermorgen
das sind rein technische fragen wir
haben auch vereinbart dass das
ministerium für auswärtige
angelegenheiten der russischen
föderation und auch auswärtiges amt der
vereinigten staaten werden auf
diplomatischem wege viele fragen
besprechen
es hat sich eine ganze reihe von fragen
gesammelt ich da beide parteien wollen
die lösungen suchen was die ukraine
angeht ja wir haben darüber gesprochen
und zwar nicht sehr ausführlich aber wie
ich herrn präsident beiden verstanden
habe die grundlage zur regelung der
situation in der ukraine sollen die
minsker vereinbarungen erliegen jetzt
was den möglichen beitritt der ukraine
zur nato
dieses thema wurde ein passant erwähnt
und wir können das jetzt nicht mehr
sprechen das ist so im großen und ganzen
wir werden bei der jetzt vertreter von
ita das bitte das mikrofon übergeben
danke sie haben gesagt dass eine der
themen aber auch die cyber stabilität
können sie auch sagen welche
entscheidungen zu dieser frage getroffen
wurden russland und die vereinigten
staaten die verhandlungen über die
strategische stabilität fortführen
werden und über die abrüstung und über
statt drei vertrag
das geplant wird weitere verhandlungen
über die überprüfung der parameter zu
diesen verträgen oder vielleicht neue
verträge ab fassen was die die
vereinigten staaten amerika und auch die
russische föderation tragen besondere
verantwortung für strategische
stabilität in der welt alleine schon
deshalb weil wir zwei größte atom
starten sind was die atomsprengköpfe und
was die qualität und das niveau und der
modernität der atomaren rüstung angeht
diese verantwortung ist uns bewusst
und ich glaube für alle ist das
offensichtlich die tatsache dass der
präsident biden eine verantwortungsvolle
entscheidung getroffen hat über die
fortsetzung der gültigkeit des vertrages
3er für fünf jahre das heißt bis zum
jahr 2024 natürlich stellt sich die
frage was weiter grund wir haben
vereinbart dass die inter amtliche
interministerielle beratungen
stattfinden eben zwischen auswärtigen
ministerium weiter stärken die kollegen
beider ministerien werden selbst
feststellen die zusammensetzung der
delegation und auch die regelmäßigkeit
solche treffen
bitteschön bitte auch ausländische
journalisten müssen auch sie denn bitte
schön danke dass mir diese frage
ermöglicht könnte zuerst einmal die
dynamik beschreiben die zwischen ihnen
und präsident weiter bestanden apparat
freundlich
oder feindselig und dann war diesen
gesprächen haben das thema cyber
angriffe auf die usa angesprochen ich
oder die bedrohung der sicherheit der
ukraine haben sie zugesagt damit
aufzuhören die opposition in russland zu
verfolgen da die gesamtbewertung der
gespräche ich bin der meinung dass es
keinerlei feierlichkeiten zu beobachten
waren im gegenteil unser begegnung war
natürlich prinzipiell wurden gespräche
geführt sind vielen dingen so haben wir
verschiedene meinungen aber von beiden
seiten wurde der wunsch demonstriert
einander zu verstehen und die wege zur
annäherung der positionen zu suchen das
gespräch war ziemlich konstruktiv was
aber die cyber sicherheit angeht wir
haben vereinbart dass wir anfangen
darüber die beratungen durchzuführen
ich meine das ist sehr wichtig jetzt wer
welche verpflichtungen übernimmt ich
möchte sie informieren über die dinge
die eigentliche bekannt sind aber nicht
den breiten publikum auch aus den
amerikanischen quellen
ich möchte jetzt die organisationen
nicht nennen weil ich die namen
vielleicht durcheinanderbringen aus
amerikanischen quellen volk das die
größten cyberangriffe und der welt aus
dem cyber raum der vereinigten staaten
durchgeführt wird an zweiter stelle
steht kanada und dann lateinamerika und
dann groß mit russland in dieser liste
von woher die größten cyberangriffe
verschiedene arten durchgeführt werden
wird nicht erwähnt
erstens 2 im verlauf von 2020 haben wir
aus den vereinigten staaten
zehn anfragen bekommen über
cyberangriffe auf die objekte die sich
in den vereinigten staaten befinden wie
unser kollegen sagen aus dem cyber raum
der russischen föderation und zwei
solcher anfragen bekommen wie in diesem
jahr und all diese fragen sowohl jahr
2002 ist auch dieses jahr haben unsere
kollegen erschöpfende antworten bekommen
ihrerseits und sein aus als hat russland
in entsprechende struktur der
vereinigten staaten führen von vier
solcher anfragen gerichtet und im ersten
hälfte dieses jahres führen von 30
solcher anfragen
wir haben keine einzige frage antwort
bekommen das heißt wir haben viel zu tun
und die frage wer in welchem umfang die
verpflichtung übernehmen soll müssen wir
ins zuge der besprechungen auch
festlegen
wir werden darüber verhandeln wir sind
der meinung dass der bereich von des
cyber sicherheit sehr wichtig ist in der
welt insgesamt und für die vereinigten
staaten ist besonderer und auch in für
russland im gleichen umfang wir wissen
bescheid über cyberangriffe gegen
pipeline in den vereinigten staaten
wir wissen dass das unternehmen
bezwungen war fünf millionen dollar
lösegeld an die erpresser bezahlen
ein teil des geldes wurde bereits zurück
aus diesen elektronischen portemonnaies
aber ein teil ist immer noch nicht
zurückgegeben was hat das mit den
staatlichen organe russland zu tun wie
wir konfrontieren mit gleichen
ereignissen zum beispiel solche angriffe
gegen das gesundheitssystem in einem der
größten einrichtungen in der russischen
föderation
wir wissen woher das kommt hier wissen
dass diese arbeit koordiniert wird aus
cyber raum der vereinigten staaten ich
glaube nicht dass die offizielle
regierungen an solche manipulation
interesse haben wir müssen einfach all
diese institution und unterstellungen
beiseiteschieben und auf der ebene der
experten uns zusammensetzen und zusammen
aber die im interesse der vereinigten
staaten und der russischen föderation
wir haben im prinzip und darüber jetzt
noch das mikrofon dem vertreter der
partie ein teil der fragen blieb
unbeantwortet wie ist es verpflichtet
angriffe auf die ukraine einzustellen
muss ganz eigenes kassierte der linie
aufgebaut und der zweite oder dritte
teil der frage was sein haben sie
verrichtet sie hervorgehen
aktives vorgehen gegen oppositionelle in
russland einzustellen
also ich habe diesen teil einfach nicht
mitgekriegt wollten sie jetzt das jetzt
was die verpflichtung gegenüber der
ukraine wir haben noch eine einzige
verpflichtung wir müssen dazu beitragen
dass die minsker vereinbarungen
umgesetzt werden wenn die ukrainische
seite bereit ist sind wir bereit diesen
weg zu gehen ohne zweifel
ich möchte sie auf folgendes hinweisen
bereits im november des letzten jahres
hat die ukrainische delegation viele
überlegen darüber vorgestellt wie sie
vorhat die minsker vereinbarungen
umzusetzen bitte sie können dieses
dokument lesen das ist nicht geheim
da steht geschrieben dass die ersten
vorschläge an geht über die politische
integration von dann was in die jugend
das ukrainische rechtssystem und in die
verfassung dafür ist es notwendig die
veränderungen in die verfassung
einzubringen
das erste und das zweite
grenze zwischen der russischen
föderation und der ukraine im bereich
von den bass
da beginnen beginn werden die von den
ukrainischen streitkräften besetzt am
nächsten tag nach den wahlen artikel 2
was hat ukraine
die streitkräfte der ukraine sollen an
die orte ihrer ständigen unterbringungs
zurückgebracht werden das heißt die
ukrainische straff kräfte müssen wieder
etwas besetzen zweitens haben sie
vorgeschlagen die grenze zwischen
russland und der ukraine in diesem
abschnitt zu schließen und drittens die
wahlen drei monate nach diesen zwei
schritten durchzuführen
denn man braucht ja kein jurist zu sein
man braucht keine fachausbildung zu
haben dass das nichts gemeinsames hat
mittels veränderung das widerspricht
ganz monogam den vereinbarungen in mist
welche verpflichtungen sollen russlands
zusätzlich übernehmen ich glaube dass es
klang das was sie manöver angeht wir
führen die manöver in unserem eigenen
hoheitsgebiet durch sowie auch die
vereinigten staaten ihre manöver im
eigenen haus gewisse wir führen keine
manöver vor der grenze der
amerikanischen grenze um mit unseren
truppen leider tun dass unsere
amerikanischen partner jetzt das heißt
es muss also unzufriedenheit nicht
seitens der ukrainische der
amerikanischen seite sein sonderseiten
der russischen aber das müssen wir auch
besprechen und die position klären
diesbezüglich unser nicht
systemimmanenten opposition und den
bürgern wenn sie meinen
person wusste bescheid dass er die in
russland gelten gesetze verletzt er
sollte als eine person die doppelt
verursacht verurteilt wurde auf
bewährung sollte er sich melden
ganz bewusst hatte diese forderung des
gesetzes ignoriert er kam ins ausland
zur behandlung die er wurde nicht
verlangt kaum hat er das krankenhaus
verlassen
dann hat er seine videos social internet
untergebracht und es entstand eine
solche forderung
er hat später erschien nicht in russland
er hat die forderung des gesetzes
ignoriert er wusste dass alles er kam
nach russland und ich glaube ganz
bewusst war er bereit festgenommen zu
werden das heißt er hat das erreicht und
dass wir dann wissen wollte was sollen
wir besprochen was überhaupt solche
person wie er angeht und überhaupt diese
system nicht immer nennt der opposition
angeht leider die zeit erlaubt uns
ausführlich darüber zu sprechen aber ich
möchte empfundene sagen ich glaube ich
werde nichts kompliziertes erzählen es
wird für jeden klar wenn sie für möglich
sein werden ihren zuhörern ihren
zuschauern das weiterzuleiten werde ich
ihnen sehr dankbar sein denn die
vereinigten staaten haben russland zum
feind und gegner erklärt das hat der
kongress im letzten jahr ihren gesetzen
der vereinigten staaten wurden
bestimmungen eingebracht das vereinigte
staaten die regeln und die ordnung der
demokratischen regierung in unserem land
unterstützen müssen und auch politische
organisationen unterstützen müssen das
steht ihnen im amerikanischen gesetzes
lassen sind uns die frage stellen wenn
russland der feind ist dann welche
organisationen soll amerika in russland
unterstützen
ich glaube bestimmt nicht die die die
russische föderation stärken
sondern die die diese die russische
föderation eben zurückhalten und das
wurde in vereinigten staaten öffentlich
erklärt das heißt das sind organisation
von sie menschen die dazu beitragen dass
die politik der vereinigten staaten in
der russischen richtung umgesetzt wird
wie sollen wir nun das betrachten wie
sollen wir dazu stehen ich glaube dass
es klar dass wir mit vorsicht das
beobachten aber wir werden handeln
ausschließlich im rahmen der
sowjetischen gesetze geben
und dann kommen wir zu a-team zugeparkt
ich wollte diese thematiken wir sind
jetzt alle zeugen dass seitens der
amerikanischen seite ständig die
rhetorik über die politische häftlinge
in russland klingt und das thema wurde
das während ihre gespräche mit beiden
gesprochen und wie wir waren alle zeugen
davon dass sie zb eine neue phase begann
mit einem groben äußerung in ihre
richtung können sie das uns erklärung ob
sie darüber gesprochen herr präsident
biden hat das thema der menschenrechte
besprochen und der menschen die der
meinung sind dass sie diese frage in der
russischen föderation vertreten
ja die haben darüber gesprochen auf
seine initiative
erstens zweitens was diese scharfen
erklärung geht ja wir kennen das alle
danach hat herr präsident biden mich
angerufen
wir haben das besprochen ich war
zufrieden damit er hat ja danach
vorgeschlagen dass wir uns treffen das
war ja seine initiative und wir haben
uns getroffen und das gespräch war sehr
konstruktiv ich hab mich noch mal
überzeugt dass herr präsident beide sehr
gefahren ist sie haben fast zwei stunden
praktisch auge-um-auge gesprochen mit
nicht mit jedem führer kann man so lange
und ausführlich sprechen was sie fuhren
unterstellungen geht da seine vorgänger
ihn bekam die gleiche frage der hat das
irgendwie ausgewichen und der präsident
der vereinigten staaten haut ist so
beantwortet seine antwort unterschied
sich von der antwort die hertrampf
damals auf diese frage machte die
prinzip alles was in unseren ländern
stattfindet dafür trägt die
verantwortung die politische führung und
die ersten persönlichkeiten in bezug
darauf wer ist da und wer wofür die
schulter sehen sie auf den straßen der
amerikanischen städte wird jeden tag
jemand umgebracht einschließlich auch
die führer von irgendwelchen führende
organisation kommen sagt man ein wörter
wird geschlossen oder man bekommt ein
messer im rücken unabhängig davon ob die
kinder stehen
eine frau hat sozusagen ist er rannte
welt und ich bekam einen schuss dann
wird das in kriminelle angelegenheiten
aber wie ist das wie ist das die sonst
werden wir in einem schlag die ganzen
hochzeits sammlungen getötet 120
menschen auf einen schlag gut aber als
zb die erschießung der drohnen oder
zivile persönlichkeiten irak was ist
dass wer trägt die verantwortung dafür
wer ist der mörder und was die
menschenrechte angeht hören sie machen
quandt teilnehmer gibt es immer noch ist
doch immer noch 1 1 das entspricht doch
nicht
weder dem völkerrecht noch den
amerikanischen gesetzen es fehlt und da
keine besitzen und trotzdem existiert
gefängnis existieren auch die von zehn
verschiedene staaten einschließlich der
europäischen hilfen braucht folter
eingesetzt wurden sind das etwa die
menschenrechte ich glaube kaum jemand
der hier sitzt im ort sagt das dass der
schutz der menschenrechte
das ist doch die praxis der realen
politik und wir gehen von dieser praxis
aus und wir verstehen dass es getan wird
und getan werden kann deswegen bauen wir
auch die unsere einstellung und das so
und auch gegenüber den personen die das
geld aus dem ausland erhalten um in
tieren die interessen derjenigen zu
verteidigen von denen sie bezahlt werden
jetzt die frage über die sie haben
gesagt sie haben über die arktis
gesprochen
seit langsam die vereinigten staaten
russland vor dass die arktis
militarisiert wird und wir haben das
schon gehört vom sekretär blinken im mai
er ist besorgt über die handlungen der
das thema haben wir im breiten format
und ziemlich ausführlich besprochen
das ist ein sehr wichtiges und
interessantes thema wenn man bedenkt
dass die erschließung der axis und
nordstraße von großem interesse ist für
die wirtschaft vieler staaten auch der
regional- und diese person ist der
amerikanischen seite über die
mediatisierung hat keine grundlage wir
machen doch da nicht was früher nicht in
der sowjetunion vorhanden war
wir stellen wieder herstellen die
infrastruktur die zerstört wurde früher
ja die machen das marschieren wir machen
dass die militärische infrastruktur die
grenz- und auch die infrastruktur zum
naturschutz wir schauen dort
entsprechende tauchbasis
für das ministerium die ausnahme
situation für den fall dass menschen
außen bei die sehr brüchigen gerettet
werden müssen und auch umweltschutz ich
habe schon unseren kollegen gesagt ich
sehe hier keinen grund zur besorgnis im
gegenteil ich glaube wir können zusammen
arbeiten viel mit lösen zusammenarbeiten
russland und die vereinigten staaten
gehören zum ach der arktischen rat geben
und zu an und zwischen alaska und jk ist
noch eine auch eine wasser wasser und
all das muss uns dazu anstoßen unser
bemühungen zu vereinigen und zu
gemeinsam dass sie das was sie nutzung
des nördlichen sehr weh dass das wird
vom völkerrecht reguliert dass es die
konvention zum see recht von 82 und auch
die nordpol a6 besteht aus etlichen
dokumenten das wurde 2017 verifiziert
und bestätigt ich habe unser partner
darauf hingewiesen dass wir russland und
wie hier sind wollen uns im vollen
umfang diese internationalen
vorschriften einheiten wir haben niemals
gegen etwas verstoßen wir sind bereit
alles zu unterstützen alle
interessierten staaten und
gesellschaften die den ort anschließen
wollen
im zuge des klimawandels wird da möglich
seien praktisch rund um das jahr und wir
werden auch eisbrecher wir werden und
wir haben die größe in der welt
eisbrecherflotte und das ist besonders
ab verlangt ich möchte in erinnerung
dass die konvention zum sehr recht der
frage
jetzt wird das dass das rechtssystem der
internationalen und gewässer beschreibt
eine stattliche gewässer immer mehr
territorialgewässer die anliegenden wir
besser und ausschließliche
wirtschaftszone und das offene meer frei
das innere gewässer dass es dass das
praktisch innerhalb des eric thorium
seines landes sich befindet der itu
reales gewässert das in zwölf seemeilen
und noch weiter anliegende noch zwölf
was die territorialen gewässer müssen
die staaten den friedlichen durchgang
einschließlich denn militärischen
schiffen verlauten dass das unser in
innerstaatliches mehr unser sehr angeht
da das geben wir natürlich keinem zur
verfügung und es gibt solche fünf solche
räumlichkeiten
das sind verschiedene solche trasse
beträgt fast 1000 seemeilen 960 meilen
aber das ist unser souveränes recht die
schiffe durch zulassen oder nicht aber
wir missbrauchen
dieses recht nicht wir geben allen die
möglichkeit wir hatten im letzten
jahrtausend anträge begonnen und wir
haben praktisch nur zehn anträge
abgelehnt und hauptsächlich waren dass
schiffe unter der russischen fahne und
unser kontrolliert kontrollierende
organe waren der meinung dass sie dem
poller cortex nicht entsprachen und
dieser polar cordex bestimmt die
anforderungen an verschiedene schiffe
und technische einrichtungen
wenn wir alle interessierten staaten
einschließlich oder vielleicht vor allem
die mitglieder des nordischen rates
gemeinsam an der bearbeitung dieser
fragen arbeiten und dann bin ich sicher
dass wir alle lösungen finden ich sehe
kein einziges problem dass wir nicht
lösen können
keine schlechten beziehungen mit
zwischen russland und amerika waren
immer unter fand der ruhe und des
friedens jetzt haben wir beiden ist
jetzt einverstanden und das gegenseitige
achtung und sie wärme waren
begleiterscheinungen dieses treffens vor
dem treffen haben sie über die roten
linien gesprochen die amerikaner haben
bestimmt auch rote linie ist es ihnen
gelungen über diese nicht überschreiten
diese roten linie dass uns die
beziehungen verbessert dass wir uns
stabilisiert ich kann ihnen sagen
insgesamt ist uns klar wovon unsere
amerikanischen partner sprechen sie
verstehen das was wir sprechen und was
wir meinen wenn wir über die roten
linien sprechen aber ich möchte ehrlich
sagen wir so weit greifend oder
ausführlich hatte etwas zu teilen
so weit sind wir nicht gekommen aber
wenn man bedenkt dass wir vereinbart
haben auch über cyber sicherheit
zusammen zu sprechen und darüber die
strategische sicherheit weiter zu
arbeiten und auch über die gemeinsame
arbeit in der axis ich glaube all das
wird mit der zeit auch gegenstand
unserer besprechung und ich hoffe auf
die förderung jetzt wissen muss unsere
amerikanischen kollegen möchten auch
eine frage stellen
das sind weiten hat erklärt er werde auf
cyber-attacken als russland reagieren
wenn es damit aufhöre hat er
irgendwelche drogen ausgesprochen
dann könnte das vielleicht ergänzen die
liste ihrer abonnenten die dozentin
gefängnis sitzen oder kann sind ist
ziemlich lang
es werden freie faire wahlen verlangt
russland hat organisation ausgeschlossen
von solchen wahlen und sie als
extremistisch bezeichnet herr präsident
meine frage wofür haben sie angst
nochmals wird er hole ich das was ich
bereits gesagt habe über die
verschiedene ausländische agenten und
auch über die personen die sich
positionierten als nicht systemimmanent
der opposition ich habe bereits ihren
kollegen geantwortet
falls ihr nein aber das ist anscheinend
soll gesetz von john ich muss vielleicht
ihre frage direkt bevor ich möchte gerne
auch noch mal wieder in den vereinigten
staaten wo das gesetz verabschiedet
wonach die vereinigten staaten erklärt
haben dass sie bestimmte politische
organisation in russland unterstützen
werden
zur gleichen zeit wurde die russische
föderation zum feind erklärt
öffentlich wurde gesagt dass sie auch
die entwicklung russlands zurückhalten
werden die frage welche politische
organisation und andere teilnehmer des
westlichen gemeinschaft wenn sie
russische in russland jemanden
unterstützen den sie auch noch dazu
bis sein wir genauso wie die amerikaner
in den 30er jahren diese person zu
ausländischen agenten erklärt haben
deren arbeit wurde allerdings nicht
besprochen
die können weitermachen die erklärung
zum ausländischen agenten stellt die
arbeit nicht ein wenn sie allerdings
extremisten sind das ist was anderes
diese organisationen sie sie erwähnt
haben die hat öffentlich zu
massenunruhen aufgerufen zur strassen
veranstaltungen und zwar der
minderjährigen dass es verboten durch
das russische gesetz und es wurden
endlich die auch anweisungen gegeben wie
man molotow-cocktails herstellt und
dabei wir dabei wird das sozusagen
gezeigt auch amerika hat vor kurzem mit
sehr komplizierten ereignissen
konfrontiert nach der ermordung eines
afroamerikaners in amerika es wurde eine
besondere black geschaffen eine bewegung
ich werde das nicht kommentieren
ich möchte nur sagen das was wir gesehen
diese hohlräume verletzungen von
gesetzen und so weiter und so fort wir
haben mitleid metern amerikaner aber wir
wollen nicht dass das in unserem
hoheitsgebiet stattfindet und werden
alles tun um das nicht zuzulassen und
irgendwelche angst hier hat das nichts
mit angst zu tun wollen sie noch was ja
beantwortet wenn alle ihre politischen
gegner tot sind inhaftiert sind wurde
vergiftet werden ist das dann nicht an
der aussage dass sie keinen fairen
politischen kampf dulden wollen jetzt
mit politischen forderungen kamen
menschen im kongress der vereinigten
staaten nicht enteilen
400 personen gegen 400 personen wurde
ein strafverfahren eingeleitet das tor
denn eine gefängnis gefängnisstrafen bis
zu 20 25 jahren sie werden durch
terroristen ernannt erklärt und zwar
werden sie 70 personen wurden sofort
nach diesen ereignissen festgenommen und
erst
30 befinden sich immer noch unter recht
warum auf welcher grundlage denn keiner
hat uns darüber informiert von den
offiziellen amerikanischen gemacht haben
einer der teilnehmer eine der
teilnehmerinnen wurde gleich an der
stelle erschossen
und dabei hat sie dem polit den
polizisten nicht mit waffen bedroht in
vielen dann passiert das gleiche was
auch bei uns ich möchte nochmals betonen
wir haben wir fühlen nachdem was in den
vereinigten staaten geht dabei wir
wollen nicht zulassen dass bei uns
dasselbe passiert bitte noch ein paar
fragen denn danach muss das programm des
präsidenten weiter fortgesetzt werden es
ist ihm gelungen mit der amerikanischen
seite über die rückführung manche die in
amerikanischen gefängnissen sich
befindet werden
wir haben darüber gesprochen biden hat
diese frage auch besprochen in anwendung
auch an die amerikanischen bürger die in
russischen gefängnissen sich befindet da
können bestimmt der kompromisse gefunden
werden
das ministerium für auswärtige
angelegenheiten und auch die kollegen in
den usa werden in dieser frage weiter
arbeiten jetzt die letzte frage
fernsehkanal mieten michael anton
russland 1 sie haben gesagt dass sie mit
herrn beiden den handel gesprochen haben
dass es wohl die positive agenda dir
sein kann welche business hat interesse
an der zusammenarbeit das hängt nicht
von uns ab das sind von der
amerikanischen seite wir führen doch
keine einschränkungen ein
ich glaube nach der einführung von
bestimmten beschränkungen im bereich der
wirtschaft des wahren austausch haben
die vereinigten staaten nicht weniger
verloren als russland ja das hat in
gewissen hinsicht unsere entwicklung von
beziehungen beeinflussen
in gewisser hinsicht hat haben die
vereinigten staaten sozusagen die
russland etwas zurückgehalten aber jetzt
was das interesse des amerikanischen
business angeht
es war die größte delegation 200 die
delegation an 200 personen haben das
petersburger wirtschaftsforum besucht
aber wegen der einschränkungen seitens
der vereinigten staaten sind die
amerikaner gegangen und haben dieses
geschäft an die konkurrenz abgegeben und
wozu bisher kein sinn aber verluste sind
da und unser handelsvolumen mit
vereinigten staaten 28 milliarden dollar
jetzt ist das im ersten quartal etwas um
1,5 prozent gestiegen und werden diese
tendenz bleibt dann werden davon alle
profitieren
wissen sie was ein paar fragen von einer
seite einfach von der anderen
also andré du musst der jungen dame doch
herr präsident ich danke ihnen sehr dass
ich dir möglich habe in einer frage zu
stellen vor ein paar jahren haben sie
schon mit herrn beiden getroffen als er
vizepräsident war er hat damals gesagt
er hat ihnen in die augen reingeschaut
und hat dort keine seele entdeckt und
sie sagten ihm sie verstehen einander
sagen sie mal haben sie in seine augen
reingeschaut haben sie in seinen augen
einen menschen gesehen mit dem sie
zusammenarbeiten können
sagen sie mal hat präsident biden sie
eingeladen ins weiße haus zu kommen
naja beiden hat mich nicht eingeladen zu
besuch ich habe das auch bis jetzt nicht
getan
ich glaube für derartige reisen und
treffen müssen die bedingungen reif
werden was aber rein schauen in die
seele etwas sehen oder nicht sehen in
der seele
wissen sie ich höre das nicht zum ersten
mal ich kann mich ehrlich gesagt gar
nicht erinnern an diese seele gespräche
das ist irgendwie an mir vorbei gesaust
aber wenn sie mich fragen welche
gesprächspartner und partner herr
präsident biden ist ich kann sagen sehr
ausgewogen konstruktiv wie ich auch
erwartet habe sie erfahren dass sieht
man gleich aber etwas sicherer nathan
seine familie hat dass eine familie
erwähnt und auch er hat sich daran
erinnert was worüber seine mutter mit
ihm gesprochen hat das sind keine dinge
die im direkten bezug haben zu unserem
gespräch aber dennoch das zeigt
irgendwie seine die qualität seiner
moralischen werte das ist
anziehend und ich glaube dass wir
insgesamt die gleiche sprache gesprochen
haben das bedeutet aber nicht dass wir
einander in die seele oder in die augen
schauen müssen und ewige liebe und
freundschaft schwören müssen nein wir
verteidigen die interessen unserer
völker und unser gelände und solche
beziehungen haben sind immer pragmatisch
die zeit jetzt die ergebnisse dieses
treffens haben sie irgendwie ich hatte
auch keine alten version gehabt woher
wir kommen sie drauf auf illusionen ich
habe keine illusionen und es kann auch
keine vision geben jetzt gehen wir in
die richtung ich weiß nicht wer das ist
also da ist ganz hinten jemand möchte
geben sie das mikrofon um diese jungen
frau und die junge frau entscheide
selbst wem sie das mikrofon überreicht
er über die globalen klimaveränderungen
ob sie darüber gesprochen haben und
zweitens über die amerikanischen
massenmedien
sie haben vor kurzem ein großes
interview wenn sie gegeben ist es denn
gerecht dass sie interview so für große
interviews an die amerikaner geben aber
die amerikanischen präsidenten geben
kein interview und und füllen sie den
einfluss diese interviews positiv an
ihre antworten immer ständig erstellt
werden oder was ach wissen sie was die
einstellung angeht was nicht genügend
gesagt wird oder so was das ist tja so
ist eben die praxis der internationalen
beziehungen heute da kann man nichts
ändern
ich bin seit langem daran gewöhnt und
damit müssen wir alle leben und leben
seit jahrzehnten
jetzt aber
welche interviews das entscheiden eben
die entsprechenden politiker oder die
seite wenn sie wollen dass menschen
etwas erfahren dann geben wir uns nur
meine interviews an die amerikanische
presse sind eben damit verbunden war es
aber die tätigkeit unserer massenmedien
angeht dann präsident biden stellte die
frage über die tätigkeit von svoboda
oder free europe in russland die wir zu
ausländischen agenten erklärt haben ich
habe den eindruck bekommen dass die
mitglieder der amerikanische delegation
wussten nicht dass davor wir haben nur
zwei solche massenmedien vorstellungen
das ist russia today und sputnik das
davor die amerikanische seite unsere
stationen praktisch zu ausländischen
agenten erklärt hat und die haben wurde
denn die akkreditierung kannst oder was
wir getan haben das war nur die antwort
wir wir verfügen sie alle vorschriften
sie müssen sich entsprechend registriert
werden
obwohl für unsere einrichtungen die
haben probleme mit personal mit
finanzierungen
wir haben keine solche probleme und
bedauerlicherweise die amerikanischen
medien erfüllen nicht die forderungen
der russischen gesetze wir haben darüber
gesprochen ich hoffe dass auch in diesem
bereich wir über das ministerium für
auswärtige angelegenheiten unserer
arbeit fortführen werden so ja ich
meinte es war eine junge frau aber okay
danke schön etwas
wir haben alle gesehen wie sie den
präsidenten
in die hand gedrückt haben und mich
frage ist es jetzt haben sie ein neues
niveau der gegenseitige verständigung
erreicht und vertrauen bekommen ist es
möglich eine neue etappe der beziehungen
so kommen dass diese beziehungen
verständigt und transparent sein werden
wissen sie man sagt man es gibt niemals
im leben dass google glück man sieht nur
aus der ferne
dieses glück sich nähren und deswegen
nur so können wir sozusagen das sehen
also die morgenröte dieses glückes ist
schon erschienen
ich bitte sie bitte das mikrofon
wohin sie noch zweiter nein weil dieses
mikrofon abgestellt
jetzt das thema des corona virus ist
natürlich sehr wichtig jetzt auf unserem
planeten haben sie das mit dem
amerikanischen präsidenten übersprungen
und wenn ja welche perspektive der
zusammenarbeit mit amerikanern um diese
zu beseitigen zu bekämpfen kann man
vielleicht gegenseitige anerkennung von
max wir haben dieses thema erwählt aber
anpassung sie wissen ja auch mal bei der
früheren west ration haben wir uns
gemeldet auf die bitte der
amerikanischen seite und wir haben als
humanitäre hilfe um technik und sand und
amerika ist ein großes mächtiges land
das ist nicht so dass sie da kein geld
haben aber sie brauchten
zu dem damaligen zeitpunkt unterstützung
wir haben das getan und wir haben das
praktisch unentgeltlich gemacht und wir
sind bereit auch in der zukunft das was
mit dem präsident nach dem treffen mit
präsident nur träumt die beziehung und
haben sich noch verschlechtert gibt es
irgendwelche faktoren dass die
verschlechterungen kürzt nach dem
jetzigen treffen haben wir jetzt den
boden erreicht mit ein bisschen besser
dass wir so nach oben gehen können es
fällt mir schwer das zu besprechen dann
alle
aktionen sie mit der verschlechterung
der russisch-amerikanischen beziehungen
verbunden sind wurden seitens der
amerikanischen seite initiiert und diese
geschäftsleute was sie sich noch
einfallen lassen das wissen wir nicht
alexandra kamp
wissen sie unsere haben gewonnen bei den
finnen 1 0 im fußball aus der gleichen
position das treffen zwischen beiden und
putin bewerten
wie würden sie das welche rechnung und
die zweite frage amerikaner bevor sie
nach genf gekommen zu haben sie gesagt
wir werden druck ausüben auf russland
auf booten haben sie diesen druck
verspürt und wie sie diesem druck sich
widersetzt haben das ist vielleicht die
wichtigste frage und sie wissen sie ich
glaube das reicht ja ich glaube auch das
reicht es gibt keinen druck ich habe
keinen druck verspürt und weil das
gespräch offen und direkt war und ohne
diplomatische
abweichungen von den vorgegebenen thema
dar
ich wiederhole noch mal dass es weder
von unserer seite noch von deren seite
gab es keinen druck das hat auch sinnlos
nicht zu diesem zweck kommen menschen
den ersten teil ihrer frage habe ich
auch so wissen sie vor unserem treffen
hat der präsident biden gesagt das ist
doch keine sportwettbewerb und ich bin
in der er sich mit dem völlig
einverstanden
das treffen war insgesamt gegenständlich
konkret und ergebnis voll und das
verlief in der atmosphäre der uns darauf
einstellte ergebnisse zu erreichen und
das wichtigste das in dieser morgenröte
des vertrauens worüber wir jetzt mit
ihrer kollegin gesprochen haben
bitteschön bbc news also herr präsident
vor beiden ruft dazu auf dass die
beziehungen mit russland berechenbar und
stabil sind aber in wessen ist man der
meinung dass die unberechenbarkeit ist
der charakterzug der russischen politik
sind sie bereit auf die
unberechenbarkeit zu verzichten einfach
um die beziehungen zu verbessern
sie sind sie haben hier ein kunst niveau
erreicht die der erste teil ihrer frage
im westen im westen
er ist man der meinung und der zweite
teil sind sie bereit darauf zu
verzichten wenn im westen so gemeint
wird das bedeutet nicht dass das so ist
erlauben sie zuerst mal ihre erste sie
haben gesagt ihm wissen ist man der
meinung dass die russische politik
außenpolitik und berechenbar ist ich
werde ihn wie ist dass der ausstieg
ausstieg der vereinigten staaten aus dem
pool vertag
2020 wieder das ist doch wozu hat man
dann auch ausstieg aus der
mittelstrecken ihrer kirche emk was was
ist da das ist doch nicht stabil und
dann ausstieg aus dem vertrag über den
offenen himmel bis das etwa stabil es
blieb doch nichts übrig und gott sei
dank herr präsident biden hat es im
bereich der strategischen stabilität
eine adäquate entscheidung getroffen
über die fortsetzung von start vertrages
für fünf jahre wenn sie jetzt die
situation und nehmen verbunden mit der
ukraine mit der creme davon kommt alles
davon tanzen wir und was gibt s stabiles
daran dass sie den staatsstreich in der
ukraine unterstützt haben als der
ehemalige präsident janukowitsch bereit
war
alle forderungen der opposition zu
erfüllen er war bereit die macht zu
verlassen ein mann musste
notable ein blutiges stadt streicht
durchführen und das führte zu
entsprechenden konsequenzen sehen sie
kosten oder ukraine und sie kriegen und
sie halten uns für unberechenbar
nein ich denke so nicht wie mir scheint
wir verhalten uns absolut adäquat den
für uns entstehenden gefahren und ich
glaube damit die situation wirklich
stabil bleibt müssen wir verhaltensregel
festlegen in allen bereichen die wir das
ist cyber sicherheit dass es die
strategische stabilität das ist die
lösung der fragen die mit regionalen
konflikten verbunden
ich bin der meinung wir können über all
diese fragen uns einigen zumindest
solchen eindruck habe ich als ergebnis
unserem eines treffens mit präsident
beiden halten
ich glaube wir müssen wir uns schon
wieder zu sehen
blauer nebel und aber die ausländischen
kollegen werden ihre lieder nicht
verstehen lassen
sie uns jemand von unseren ausländischen
kollegen bloomberg bitteschön blumberg
und dann geht es zu ende
das ist nur die letzte frage blumberg
2016 nach dem treffen mit wurden ganz
schnell amerikanische sanktionen
verabschiedet haben sie heute bei den
verhandlungen mit beiden die signale
dass seitens der amerikanische seite in
der zukunft keine sensationen
vorgenommen werden und auch über die
ergebnisse dass sie sagten da so
morgenröte des vertrauens haben sie aus
der sicht der erfüllbarkeit der anfangs
vereinbarungen haben sie mehr vertrauen
und sicherheit dass mehr getan wird denn
man ist der meinung dass der
amerikanische apparat administration
mehr einverstanden ist mit der politik
von beiden als früher mit trump und hier
ist auch diese fragen über die
ergebnisse der cyber sicherheit über die
ukraine über cyber sicherheit wurde ja
seine arbeitsgruppe gegründet und auch
die roten linien haben sie das
festgelegt können sie das jetzt über
diese roten linien
das ist das verständnis entsteht im zuge
der verhandlungen in den schlüssel
ausrichtungen der zusammenarbeit ist es
nicht ein ander einzuschüchtern
wenn menschen sich treffen um die
beziehungen aufzubauen weil man das
macht dann braucht man sich nicht zu
treffen was die sanktionen angeht die
einschränkungen in der wirtschaft ich
habe schon gesagt wir wissen nicht was
für ihre politische stimmungen sind wie
die kräfteverhältnisse aussehen
wir wissen zwar aber die können nicht
bis ins detail die ereignisse verstehen
es gibt die gegner der entwicklung der
beziehungen mit russland es gibt
anhänger frische kräfte
ob sie den werden weiß ich nicht das
fällt mir schwer zu sagen wenn nach
unserem treffen die
schritte unternommen werden an diese
sicheren ort haben aus dem jahr 2060 was
wir dass das wird die nächste so zu
entgangener möglichkeiten und das ist ja
in der tat die schlussfrage einen
journalisten aus kanada herr präsident
ich bedanke mich für die möglichkeit sie
etwas zu fragen ich komme aus kanada sie
haben eine reihe meiner kollegen gesagt
sie hätten keine vorteile haben wir das
richtig übersetzt bekommen
vorhin hören sie mich jetzt ich höre
keine übersetzung ich höre gar nichts
bitte versuchen sie ein über in anderen
kanal
ich höre nichts jetzt einen blick es
geht gleich los
[Musik]
danke ich komme aus kanada und möchte
sie etwas fragen japan 3 von kollegen
gesagt sie wollten vorteils freie faire
fragen haben
ich habe eine frage meiner neunjährigen
tochter die bevor ich hier in reiste
gefragt hat das ist auch nicht so
wichtig an diesem treffen was wohl einen
neuen gesichtern könnten sie das mal in
ihren eigenen worten erläutert der
präsident deshalb sind diese beziehungen
so kompliziert und meine tochter wüsste
genauso gerne wie ich weshalb junge
menschen in russland nicht protestieren
dürfen
ja das ist gut dass ihre neunjährige
tochter sich interessiert für all die
fragen wären einfach die zu beantworten
man muss einfach um sich gucken und
sagen sehen wie schön diese welt doch
ist und die erwachsenen menschen die
führer zwei staaten der größten atomaren
staaten treffen sich zusammen um diese
welt sicher und ungefährlich zu machen
zu einem aufblühen haus für alle
einwohner unseres planeten
sie werden die fragen besprechen die
verbunden sind mit schrecklichen waffen
die eingeschränkt werden müssen und dass
da die gemeinsame regeln zur
nichtanwendung ausgearbeitet werden
müssen sie werden über den umweltschutz
damit die flüsse sauber sind damit diese
sauber sind damit es zu keinen
überschwemmungen kommt dass es zu keinen
trocken halten dies für alle menschen
genug nahrung da ist unabhängig davon wo
die menschen leben sie werden sprechen
über die fragen und gesundes
gesundheitswesen denn die kinder groß
gezogen dass sie in weniger krank werden
dass sie studieren können dass sie
sicher in die zukunft schauen können ich
möchte sehr gerne dass unser gemeinsames
treffen sie meine damen und herren
ebenso beleuchten auf der grunde diese
überlegungen ich danke ihnen sehr dass
er sogar das fazit des russischen
präsidenten das fazit dieses treffens
mit dem amerikanischen präsidenten
werden natürlich gleich auf die
pressekonferenz von joe biden übertragen
auf einem monitor sehe ich bereits ja
und sie sehen es jetzt auch dass er da
ist aufgebaut ist und man war so höflich
zu warten bis wladimir putin mit seiner
pressekonferenz zu ende war
ich würde sagen wir nutzen die zeit ganz
kurz und schalten einmal zu professor
thomas jäger in die detailanalyse werden
wir noch gehen aber sagen sie doch
einfach mal so so auch ein bisschen aus
dem bauch heraus wie ist ihr erster
eindruck wie hat putin sich geschlagen
ich will das mal mit den augen der
amerikanischen delegation sehen
und die werden gesagt haben dass wir
präsident biden nicht in dieses
pressekonferenz gelassen haben dass er
sozusagen mit neben präsident putin
besprechen muss das war die richtige
entscheidung denn präsident putin hat
das gemacht was er in interviews häufig
macht eigene vorwürfe und oder vorwürfe
die ihm gegenüber gegeben werden
sozusagen wie ein gokart zu nehmen und
die anderen auf den boden zu werfen und
das ist etwas das hat er nun wirklich in
einer antwort lich ausgezeichneten weise
hier gemacht so dass er alle programme
kamen abgewehrt hat ob das glaubwürdig
ist es eine ganz andere frage und das
andere ist ja doch die wichtige in form
aktion das ist ein konstruktives
gespräch gewesen sein soll und dass man
verschiedene gebiete jetzt identifiziert
hat auf denen weiter gearbeitet wird
wenn mehr konnte man in diesem frühen
stadium der amerikanischen
präsidentschaft gar nicht erwarten als
dass jetzt die fachleute ran kommen und
dann eben lösungen ausarbeiten die dann
möglicherweise wieder zurück gespiegelt
werden an die präsidenten um politische
entscheidungen zu treffen da ist ein
ganzes tableau jetzt schon besprochen
worden
aber die auseinandersetzung gegen die
präsident biden hätte gehen müssen den
den tod von jobs neu zu verteidigen
die amerikanische polizei gewalt zu
verteidigen das wasser nicht gekonnt
hätte sondern er hätte so zu sagen da
gestanden und hätte in gegenseitige
vorwürfe hinein gehen müssen das hätte
die die einen konstruktiven gibt es
sozusagen in der sekunde zerstört
tatsächlich hat laut putin ja beide bei
der frage nach einer weile und nach der
russischen opposition und nach dem
umgang mit gegnern politischen gegnern
im eigenen land hat sehr sehr schnell
gekontert und hat ja genau das was sie
gerade skizziert haben genannt und hat
ja auch den usa damit schwere vorwürfe
gemacht glauben sie dass die beiden auch
wirklich darüber gesprochen haben oder
war das jetzt sozusagen eine einseitige
interpretation ausschließlich von putin
die fragen sind nach auskunft von
präsident gute hier nur sozusagen
nebenbei angesprochen worden und
wahrscheinlich haben sie die beiden
präsidenten das nicht gegenseitig gesagt
die amerikanische seite weiß wie die
russische argumentierte und die
russische weiß wie die amerikanische
argumentiert entscheidend ist hier das
bild das nach außen gegeben wird und das
ist dass der russische präsident sich
hinstellt und sagt wir sind ein starker
berechenbarer staat und die vereinigten
staaten sind momentan im niedergang
es ist ein land das tief gespalten ist
das politische gefangene macht indem man
auf den straßen erschossen wird oder ein
messer in den
bekommt und wir wollen diese
verhältnisse ja nicht haben und das
wenigste war noch zu sagen wenn
journalisten ihre akkreditierung
verlieren dann ist das ja nur die
reaktion darauf dass andere das auch
verloren haben also dieses diese ist
immer wieder was ist eigentlich bei euch
los das ist eine rhetorische figur wie
präsident putin hervorragend beherrscht
das ist eine figur die er immer wieder
anwendet und die dann aber eben
gemeinsame pressekonferenzen wirklich
platzen lässt
wie war der umgang mit dem thema ukraine
dem konnte putin nicht ausweichen das
ist mit sicherheit zwischen den beiden
auch erörtert worden
wie hat putin sich da raus laviert er
hat eine klare position eingenommen
das ist die russische position die es
hier gibt der westen hat in der ukraine
einen blutigen staatsstreich unterstützt
mit dem euro weiter und da fing alle
probleme an es gibt dann mit der minsker
vereinbarung einen möglichen lösungsweg
den die ukraine blockiert so immer noch
weiter die russischen sicht und wenn
russland manöver in an seiner westgrenze
ausübt dann ist das auf eigenem
territorium und geht eigentlich niemand
anders etwas an
das ist die position auf die sich
russland zurück zieht und die frage wird
sein ob es jetzt nach diesem gespräch
auf der basis der minsker vereinbarungen
eben fortschritte geben kann oder ob man
hier feststellen muss die interessen
sind doch so unterschiedlich dass man
eben nicht auf einen gemeinsamen weg
kommt und den konflikt schlicht nur
eingefroren halten kann
wir halten sie es für denkbar dass die
minsker vereinbarung wenn sie den ernst
genommen würde dazu führen könnte dass
sich beide seiten da konstruktiv
unterhalten
ja da steht erstmal die cam davor und
die annexion der krim die jetzt
sozusagen das hauptproblem ist das
völkerrechtlich auf dem tisch liegt und
dann geht es um die frage wie welche
form von autonomie im osten der ukraine
gewährt wird
es geht um die frage wie die verfassung
geändert wird wie die korruption
bekämpft werden kann im land der
amerikanische präsident hat vorher schon
auf seiner reise gesagt die ukraine hat
relativ viel zu leisten bisher am start
wird mit dem wir etwa in der nato
gemeinsam arbeiten können nicht als
mitglied aber sozusagen in einer in
einem weg dorthin
das wird russland nicht akzeptieren und
auch wenn präsident putin gesagt hat man
braucht ja über rote linie nicht reden
dann braucht man sich gar nicht treffen
ist das etwas was die amerikanische
seite weist ein nato-mitglied ukraine
ist büros land schlicht nicht hinnehmbar
und die frage wird sein kann man hier
eine lösung finden die allen irgend
allen interessen irgendwie gerecht wird
das ist die frage die sozusagen momentan
die quadratur des kreises darstellt wo
man sich aber ja lösungen denken kann
die jetzt wahrscheinlich in den
auswärtigen ämtern beider staaten
ventiliert werden
tatsächlich hat putin ihr vorhin auch
erwähnt dass die ukraine tendenzen zeigt
sich der nato nähern zu wollen und er
hat durchblicken lassen dass russland
das natürlich ablehnt wie sehr glauben
sie leidet putin leidet russland
tatsächlich darunter das ja viele
ehemalige sowjetische starten jetzt
durchaus teil der nato geworden sind und
das ist etwas was er ja als die größte
geopolitische katastrophe des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts bezeichnet hat
der untergang der sowjetunion und die
staaten die schon in der nato sind
insbesondere die baltischen staaten in
der eu sind die sind sozusagen schon auf
der anderen seite aber es gibt eine
ganze reihe starten vom georgien über
die ukraine bis weißrussland für die die
russische regierung die die dominante 1
den dominanten einfluss reklamiert das
sieht sie als ihre einflusszone an
kein anderer staat was zu suchen hatte
ihr amerikaner sehen das anders und so
georgien als auch die ukraine sind ja
nun bestrebt auf dem weg zu einer
nato-mitgliedschaft der sogenannten map
nun voran zu gehen der der ukrainische
präsident macht da überhaupt keinen
zweifel trasse hat hingegen sogar drauf
ist darauf gedrungen vor dem treffen
beiden putin selbst mit beiden zu
sprechen
diese provokation aus russischer sicht
jetzt wieder haben die amerikaner
unterlassen und die salomonische
entscheidung was die ukrainische
verbindung zur nato angeht ist eben
momentan die sprachregelung prinzipiell
nicht ausgeschlossen aber noch sehr sehr
weit weg und jetzt kommt es darauf an ob
man kreative ideen hat in dieser auf
diesem weg der noch so weit weg ist und
da spielt eben die frage der generellen
annäherung von russland und den
vereinigten staaten möglicherweise auf
ganz anderen gebiet eine viel größere
rolle
der handel ist angesprochen worden in
dem präsident putin darauf hinwies dass
die amerikaner mit einer großen
delegation zum gerade erst stattfinden
petersburger wirtschaftsforum gekommen
sind und dann nachschub naja auf die
geschäfte mussten sie erleben verzichten
die konnten sie hier nicht machen
und vielleicht ist der hand wirklich
eine möglichkeit der
wirtschaftsbeziehungen eine möglichkeit
wie beide staaten dann doch in bessere
beziehungen zueinander kommen können und
ein anderer meilenstein könnte sein dass
man eben doch auf dem vielfach
angesprochenen gebiet der cyberangriffe
der cyberangriffe das cyber kriminalität
zu vereinbarungen kommt die dann doch
tragfähig sind nur da geht so sehr in
die details das müssen fachleute
ausarbeiten
da muss auch das vertrauen hergestellt
werden sich gegenseitig an monitoring
zuzugestehen dass das etwas ist was man
sicher nicht in wenigen monaten erwarten
kann dass es umgesetzt wird
ich würde gerne an dieser stelle eine
europäische stimme hört
der europäische außenbeauftragte borel
hat eine dreiteilige strategie zum
künftigen umgang mit russland
vorgeschlagen die eu müsse moskau
zurückdrängen einschränken und einbinden
so hat er es gesagt er wird das gleich
selber sagen er sagt jetzt relativ
drastisch und relativ klar wir gehen ein
kleines bisschen übrigens setzt das sage
ich ihnen ganz ehrlich liebe zuschauerin
zuschauer das risiko ein dass joe biden
in der zwischenzeit anfängt zu reden und
haben gesagt wir werden natürlich live
übertragen das würden wir dann tun
aber keine sorge hervor ellwürden wir
danach reichen aber zunächst mal hat der
eu außenbeauftragte das wort remains die
robinien lage ist russland ist immer
noch der größte nachbar der europäischen
union ein wichtiger globaler akteur im 3
die bewusste politische meinungsbildung
und die entscheidungen russlands im
kreise die regierung während der letzten
jahre
diese entscheidungen haben leider in
unseren beziehungen zu einer
negativspirale geführt die strategischen
herausforderungen die durch die
russische führung herbeigeführt worden
sind in verbindung mit unseren
leitsätzen unseren fünf leitsätzen haben
für die eu eine zielsetzung geben bei
der unsere interessen und werte
verteidigt werden
die europäische union hat sie einmal wir
eigentlich gezeigt trotz der versuche
russland uns zu spalten
diese einheit diese geschlossenheit ist
unser wichtigster pluspunkt und muss
weiter ausgebaut werden
unter den gegenwärtigen umständen in der
überzeugung dass wir mit einer erneuten
partnerschaft das volle potential einer
engen zusammenarbeit mit russland
ausschöpfen können
im augenblick ist das eine
situation die ich als fernziel
beschreiben möchte wir müssen
realistisch bleiben wir müssen bereit
sein als europäische union einen
weiteren abschwung eine weitere
verschlechterung unserer beziehungen mit
russland ins auge zu fassen
sie stehen heute schon auf einem
tiefpunkt und diese weitere
verschlechterung ist im augenblick die
wahrscheinlichste zukunft mit dem wir
uns auseinandersetzen müssen wir müssen
darum den ehrgeiz zeigen versuche zu
unternehmen die derzeitige dynamik
allmählich zu verwandeln und zu
verändern in eine berechenbare und
stabilere beziehung mit der heutigen
mitteilung wollen wir zugleich
zurückdrängen einengen und einbinden
wir wollen russland zurückdrängen ein
englisch und einbinden
auf der grundlage unseres gemeinsamen
verständnisses der ziele russlands und
eines ansatzes den wir als pragmatisch
und prinzipien orientiert beschreiben
können ich möchte auf diese drei
begriffe näher eingehen
zuerst einmal müssen wir russland zurück
drängen wenn es um
menschenrechtsverletzungen geht um
verstöße gegen das völkerrecht in den
mitgliedstaaten und in unserer
unmittelbaren nachbarschaft müssen uns
weiterhin für demokratische werte
einsetzen
das sind anliegen unmittelbare anliegen
aller mitglieder der vereinten nationen
aller oecd mitglieder und alle
mitgliedstaaten des europarats
und das gehört nicht klassisch
betrachtet zu den inneren
angelegenheiten eines landes was den
grundlegenden bereich hiervon angeht
werden wir uns weiterhin für die ukraine
einsätzen für die kirche gerade
integrität souveränität und
unabhängigkeit des landes dazu gehört es
russland weiterhin aufzufordern seine
verantwortung als konfliktpartei zu
übernehmen und die entsprechenden mittel
einzusetzen
wir müssen zweitens russland einengen
denn das land hat sucht die interessen
der europäischen union zu beschneiden
die eu muss robuster und
widerstandsfähiger werden
und dabei müssen wir auch unsere cyber
sicherheit und unsere cyber abwehr
fähigkeit ausbauen und daneben auch an
unseren strategischen
kommunikationsmöglichkeiten denken an
unsere fähigkeiten diesem bereich im
wirken gegen meinungsmanipulation und
desinformation
wir müssen unsere fähigkeiten ausweiten
das hybride bedrohungen anbelangt müssen
auch die vorteile nutzen die unsere
energiepolitik
der übergang in unserer energiepolitik
mit sich bringt wir müssen unsere
nachbarn dabei unterstützen unser
energie übergang der wandel unserer
energiepolitik wird russland direkt
berühren
angesichts unseres künftigen energie lag
sie wissen ja dass russland riesige
mengen an kohlenwasserstoffen im rahmen
dieses energiemix zurzeit liefert wir
müssen auch unsere partner im osten
verstärkt unterstützen und ihre
widerstandskraft ausbauen indem wir die
ausstehenden reformen verwirklichen
und die ist dort ermöglichen und
drittens und das ist ebenfalls ein
wichtiger punkt müssen russland
einbinden müssen russland bei
verschiedenen entscheidenden aufgaben
einziehen damit wir an dieser stelle
unsere interessen besser wahren können
sie wissen ja dass die kogit 19 pandemie
die notwendigkeit deutlich gemacht hat
er sich weltweit für die öffentliche
gesundheit einzusetzen
die europäische union und russland haben
eine gemeinsame grenze von 2000
kilometer länge wir sind nachbarn
wir brauchen einen engen dialog mit
russland zur bekämpfung des klimawandels
im vorfeld der kopf 26 klimakonferenz
ende des jahres in glasgow drittens
müssen wir dann auch die fachlichen
auseinandersetzung mit der russischen
regierung angehen es gibt ja eine reihe
von problemen punkten in unseren
beziehungen
wir müssen darüber hinaus die
zwischenmenschlichen beziehungen
verbessern
verstärkte ausgabe von dieser gerade
auch für junge menschen studenten
wissenschaftliches lehrpersonal
austauschprogramme der nächste punkt
besteht dann darin dies alles weiterhin
zu unterstützen und mehr flexibilität
und kreativität zu zeigen
im kontakt mit der zivilgesellschaft in
russland und mit verfechtern der
menschen richtet
und schließlich müssen wir an der
außenpolitischen front weiterhin in
regionalen fragen zusammenarbeiten
davon gibt es viele nahen osten in
afghanistan oder libyen unter beispiele
zu nennen
wir müssen auch in globalen fragen bei
der terrorismusbekämpfung der
nichtverbreitung von kernwaffen
kooperieren
das sind die vorschläge die wir zusammen
mit der kommission erarbeitet haben
wir haben entwürfe in dieser richtung
vorgelegt um unsere beziehung zu
russland weiter auszugestalten
die wirtin auch künftig eng mit unseren
partnern der g7 und der nato und anderen
gleichgesinnten partnern
zusammenarbeiten
wir müssen die beziehungen so
vorantreiben dass unsere interessen und
grundsätze besser gewahrt und gefördert
werden können
diese mitteilung wird also die
gesprächsgrundlage für den europäischen
rat in der nächsten woche bilden und das
ist die grundlage die wir haben hier
einstellen können und davon gehen wir
aus soweit also der außenbeauftragte der
europäischen union borel mit seiner
stellungnahme
wir können ja einmal kurz zum ort der
pressekonferenz von joe biden schauen
das bild haben sie eben klein gesehen
jetzt sehen sie ist groß wir waren
sozusagen wir warten jeden moment darauf
dass der amerikanische präsident mit
seiner sicht auf diesen gipfel in genf
blickt und ich würde sagen wir nutzen
die zeit aber wir nutzen die zeit und
sprechen noch einmal kurz mit thomas
jäger der politikwissenschaftler thomas
jäger in aschaffenburg dem kölner
politikwissenschaftler was borel gerade
gesagt hat und wir hatten ja vorher
darüber gesprochen über die
empfindlichkeiten russlands was zum
beispiel mögliche ansinnen der ukraine
trifft der nato beizutreten
wie sehr kann europa wie sehr kann die
eu denn als brückenbauer zwischen
russland und amerika von gut fungieren
in irgendeiner weise als diplomatische
vermittler gar nicht das ist eine kurze
und schnelle antwort nein die
europäische union überschätzt sich
und wenn man zuhört dann denkt man ja ja
das ist schon alles irgendwie richtig
aber es fehlen hat die fähigkeiten genau
das umzusetzen
die europäische union hat auch die
annexion werden können sich die
völkerrechtliche völkerrechtswidrige
annexion der krim so was es heißt in
einer art und weise reagiert russland
nicht wirklich tangiert hat die
europäische union hat ja das münchner
abkommen zu vertreten gehabt das ist ja
im norma die format verhandelt worden
also russland die ukraine frankreich und
deutschland
und es ist sozusagen eingeschlafen und
die europäer haben überhaupt keine kraft
das wieder zum leben zu erwecken diese
kraft haben die vereinigten staaten
insofern das lässt sich fortsetzen wenn
man will sagt man wolle russland
einbinden in fragen der nuklearen
proliferation oder der
terrorismusbekämpfung oder der
regionalpolitik in allen drei fragen
sind die ist die europäische union an
sich und sind die eu staaten überhaupt
keine partner für die für russland
also das war wenn sie so wollen ein aus
der eu allerdings gewohntes statement
der völligen selbstüberschätzung und wo
man sich fragen muss in welcher realität
denn die europäische union ihre politik
konzipiert und nein die europäische
union wird nicht der brückenbauer
zwischen den usa und russland sein
sondern im gegenteil sie muss acht geben
wenn die beiden miteinander im gespräch
sich dass sie weiß auf welcher seite sie
steht um nicht missachtet zu werden
ziemlich klare antwort an dieser stelle
vielleicht eine frage die sich auf joe
biden bezieht denn ich vermute dass die
live übertragung seiner rede jetzt
gleich beginnen wird warum hat er
eigentlich einer live übertragung des
gesamten treffens nicht zugestimmt
welche ziele sind denn für beiden hinter
verschlossenen türen besser zu verfolgen
als in der öffentlichkeit
das wäre generell keine gute idee
gewesen dass öffentlich zu übertragen
denn das hätte genießen beide seiten
sagen das was sie voneinander sowieso
schon wissen und man hätte im
hintergrund dann doch wieder die türen
zugemacht und da werden den wirklichen
gespräche geführt worden
nein solche verhandlungen brauchen ihren
schutzraum wenn man so will um dann
einen austausch zu ermöglichen
der eben nicht direkt an die
öffentlichkeit kommt und deswegen
kriegen wir ja auch nicht eins zu eins
gespiegelt was dort geschehen ist
sondern der russische präsident spricht
zu seinem publikum der amerikanische
springreiter mclain kumm wir werden ja
jetzt wenn joe biden spricht darauf
achten wo sind denn die differenzen in
den beiden statements gibt es
überschneidungen und geht er in die
gleiche richtung all das wird ja jetzt
beobachtet werden aber für joe biden war
ist vor allem ein wichtiger punkt eben
nicht gemeinsam mit präsident putin auf
einer pressekonferenz aufzutreten weil
man wusste wie der russische präsident
argumentiert und wusste dass der
amerikanische präsident daher wirklich
eine ganz schwierige lage kommt denn die
kritik an den wehren der am zustand der
demokratie in den usa die würde schon
beiden ganz anders mit einem ganz
anderen zungenschlag mit einer ganz
anderen zielrichtung auf einer ganz
anderen grundlage aber die hat er ja
auch er sagte auch wir müssen um unsere
demokratie kämpfen
er geht eben nicht her wie das präsident
putin gemacht hat und sagt na ja die
vereinigten staaten sind sozusagen jetzt
auf dem auf dem weg sich selbst zu
verlieren auf den weg ihr eigenes land
zu zerstören was nicht von außen
zerstört wurde wie das schon abraham
lincoln gesagt hat sondern nur von innen
kommen kann wenn wir uns nicht mehr wir
amerikaner bewusst sind dass wir ein
land der selbstregierung sind dass wir
uns selbst vergewissern müssen welches
volk wir sind und das ist etwas was so
beiden ja aufgreift und im wahrsten
wortsinn reparieren will und das wäre
eine ganz unglückliche gemenge lage
geworden wenn er auf die
argumente die präsident putin hier eben
vortrag darauf hätte antworten müssen
professor jäger wir schauen es noch
einmal an die stelle an der die beiden
gleich sprechen wird möchte dass wir
noch einmal diesen aufgebauten set das
rednerpult vor dem see uns anschauen
aber ich sag mal so ich würde
vorschlagen wir lernen jetzt also eine
erfahrung die wir diese woche schon
einmal gemacht haben da haben wir
nämlich anderthalb stunden lang auf joe
biden gewartet und wir wechseln jetzt
einfach mal kurz das thema ich nenne es
jetzt einfach noch mal gedankensprung
wir gucken zu corona gucken was erreicht
wurde
die zwischenbilanz in dieser woche
könnte nämlich die schwelle
überschritten werden dass mehr als 50
prozent der bevölkerung eine erste
impfung erhalten haben
so hat es der bundesgesundheitsminister
ausgedrückt mit die lieferungen der
hersteller also wie geplant anhalten
dann könnten alle personen die sich
impfen lassen wollen bis ende juli
anfang august ein impf angebot
wahrnehmen ihre dienste übrigens hat
auch die korona app schon geleistet vor
einem jahr wurde sie eingeführt wir
blicken kurz zurück aber keine sorge wir
bleiben ganz in der nähe des
amerikanischen präsidenten
sie sollte eine art geheimwaffe werden
im kampf gegen die pandemie die korona
waren app entwickelt so nachverfolgung
von infektionsketten doch experten
kritisieren schon ihr staat sei zu spät
gekommen
für uns alle war natürlich dieser
prozess neu auch für die regierung
allerdings hätte man sehr viel früher
schon im ausland schauen können welche
verschiedenen versionen von solchen apps
und nach verfolgungs systemen es gibt in
korea zum beispiel war man sehr sehr
früh dran damit und schließen system
hätte man lernen können
bisher wurde die app mehr als 28
millionen mal heruntergeladen laut
bundesregierung konnten so knapp drei
millionen menschen vor möglichen
infektionen gewarnt werden
ein weiterer pluspunkt der datenschutz
durch dezentralität und anonymität geht
die korona waren es sehr geringe risiken
ein und hatte auch in dem jahr ihres
bestehens keine nennenswerten sicherheit
zurück inzwischen gibt es auch eine
check in funktion zur registrierung von
kunden und gästen doch auch hier waren
andere schneller
viele leben nutzen seit ende des
lockouts di luca auch für dieses lokal
ist die korona waren app nun keine
option mehr
also wir benutzen luca und wenn wir dass
ich gezwungen werden vom senat oder von
der bundesregierung werden wir auch
dabei 30 neue funktionen etwa das
einscannen des imf nachweises sollen
ihre rolle in der pandemie bekämpfung
künftig noch mehr stärken
die ab heute tatsächlich zu dem
schweizer taschenmesser ausgebaut werden
dass sie jetzt schon in grundzügen ist
ein jahr corona waren app die bilanz
durchwachsen
das ist ja prima sie können auf dem
kleinen bildschirm verfolgen wann joe
biden kommt und sie werden dann mit
kriegen und wenn wir sehr schnell
umschalten aber wir bleiben noch ein
bisschen in deutschland wir bleiben noch
ein bisschen bei corona die
gesundheitsminister von bund und ländern
die setzen trotz sinkender corona zahlen
nämlich weiter auf eine absicherung
ihrer breit angelegten tests strategie
auch mit blick auf die sommerreisezeit
an der generellen test flicht für
flugreisende aus dem ausland vor dem
abflug soll festgehalten werden teilte
das bayerische ressort als vorsitzland
nach beratungen mit bundesminister
sparen mit die quarantäne regeln für
rückkehrer aus risiko und hoch incidents
gebieten mit hohen infektionszahlen
sowie aus gebieten mit neuen virus
varianten sollen außerdem bestehen
bleiben
straßen- und bahnverkehr an den grenzen
soll es verstärkt kontrollen geben
die zahlen entwickeln sich erfreulich
was erste impfungen angeht aber vor
allem auch zwei impfungen die gerade in
dieser zeit wo wir ja noch über die
delta mutation reden ein ganz wichtiges
element sind der komplette impfschutz
von daher glaube ich sind wir gemeinsam
in den bundesländern auf einem guten weg
und auch in bayern auf einem sehr guten
weg es waren verschiedenste
fragestellungen die auch für die zukunft
uns noch beschäftigen werden
das thema zum beispiel der
auffrischungsimpfungen wann sind die
notwendig in welchen abständen brauchen
wir die wir waren uns da einige auch mit
dem bundesminister dass wir dazu noch
einmal separat auch mit dem paul ehrlich
institut mit dem lkw und den fachleuten
ein gespräch führen
in welchem intervall eine
auffrischungsimpfung notwendig ist und
wie wir damit umgehen das thema
impfzentren war ein ganz zentraler punkt
die impfzentren sind ja bis zum 30.09
finanziert wir haben in bayern und in
zentren wie aus meiner sicht exzellente
arbeit leisten an dieser stelle auch
noch mal den oberbürgermeistern
oberbürgermeistern und landräten ein
herzliches dankeschön für diese gute
arbeit aber natürlich auch eine der
tragenden säulen zusammen mit der
ärzteschaft die fachärzte wie hausärzte
und die betriebsärzte wir glauben dass
wir überlegen müssen wie wir über den 30
hinaus mit diesem thema gemeinsam in den
ländern umgehen das hängt natürlich
immer auch vom zufluss des impfstoffs ab
wie schnell der fortschritt auch beim
impfen gemeinsam funktioniert ich will
mal von den impfzentren 2.0 sprechen
ich glaube wir brauchen eine
weiterentwicklung dieser impfzentren wir
haben uns sehr intensiv über das thema
testen noch mal unterhalten der
bundesminister sich auch noch was dazu
sagen
die neue test verordnung und natürlich
auch das thema wie können wir bei der
einreise auch mithelfen und mit
unterstützen
dass die menschen sich testen lassen es
gibt ja die einreise quarantäne
verordnung des bundes und wir waren uns
einig dass wir jetzt eigentlich keine
neuen tests mehr aufbauen müssen wie es
damals der fall war im letzten jahr zum
beispiel
an anderen stellen sondern dass wir
genügend kapazitäten geschaffen haben um
eine gute infrastruktur anzubieten die
wir dann auch nutzen wollen und auf die
wir auch letztendlich hinweisen wollen
ein wichtiges und zentrales thema ist
das thema kinder- und jugendgesundheit
das ist auch ein thema dass bayern bei
dieser gesundheitsministerkonferenz von
anfang an als schwerpunktthema mit
eingebracht hat weil wir einfach dort
sehen dass kinder und jugendliche in
dieser pandemie auch gelitten haben und
dass diese gruppe auch besonders
betroffen waren
deswegen wollen wir uns um diese gruppe
kümmern wir wollen uns darum kümmern wie
zum beispiel das thema impfen in der
zukunft weitergehen kann da gibt es ja
erst der empfehlungen der stiko aber ich
glaube das muss man einfach weiter auch
im auge haben auch im auge haben uns ist
sehr sehr wichtig und deswegen haben wir
uns jetzt schon mitte juni auch noch mal
mit den einreisen rund um den urlaubs
und sommerreiseverkehr beschäftigt dass
das weiterhin mit viel vorsicht und
umsicht geschieht dass wir sehr klar
haben dass wir aus risikogebieten
zurückkehrt zehn tage in quarantäne muss
außer er weist aktiv eine negativ
testung nach des hochintelligenten
gebieten zurück kehrt nach deutschland
oder einreise nach deutschland
110 tage quarantäne und frühestens nach
fünf tagen frei testung möglich wer aus
virusvarianten gebieten aktuell
brasilien südafrika indien vereinigtes
königreich nach deutschland einreist 14
tage quarantäne
ohne die möglichkeit der entsprechenden
frei testung dass das nochmal sehr klar
ist dass wir auf rufen auch alle die
testmöglichkeiten wir jetzt also wer
sich ein letztes jahr erinnert hatten
wir engpass ja nicht mal genug tests im
angebot für alle die wieder eingereist
sind das ist dieses jahr anders und
deswegen wollen wir eben dass die
testmöglichkeiten auch genutzt werden
und wir haben vereinbart dass die
verpflichtung bei jedem flug aus dem
ausland nach deutschland
dass man sich testen muss und negativ
test haben muss vor dem boarding vor dem
betreten des flugzeugs auch erhalten
bleiben soll
das ist sehr sehr wichtig einfach für
sicheres reisen und auch niedrige in
studenzen im sommer zumal eines ihm
bleibt wir wollen virusvarianten so weit
es geht aus dem land oder so lange es
geht
irgendwann wahrscheinlich wird es schwer
sein alles zu verhindern in der
entwicklung wie wir an der britischen
mutation gesehen haben wir wollen sie so
lange als möglich auch nicht an einem
tag nach deutschland haben weil umso
weiter die impfkampagne fortgeschritten
ist desto schwerer als jede mutation
sich hier auch auszubreiten und gerade
mit blick auf die mutation delta ist uns
das sehr sehr wichtig also reisen ja
aber bitte weiterhin mit vorsicht und
umsicht
soviel zum thema corona soweit unser
kurzer ausflug nach deutschland wir
schauen jetzt noch einmal wieder an den
genfer see schauen noch einmal auf das
aufgebaute rednerpult des amerikanischen
präsidenten der ja schon vor längerer
zeit mit seiner rede und zu einem
interview hätte beginnen sollen aber ich
denke jetzt bewegt sich ja sie sehen es
ja selber museen nicht erklären aber ich
denke mal wenn jetzt sozusagen die
getränke gebracht werden das rednerpult
noch einmal geprüft wird dann würde ich
sagen ist es vermutlich hoffentlich sehr
bald soweit übrigens sobald der
amerikanische präsident hier redet
begrüßen wir dann auch wieder den
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer von
tagesschau 24 den tagesschau 24 und
phoenix übertragen diese
pressekonferenzen gemeinsam und jetzt
glaube ich wird es gleich losgehen
ja so kann es passieren
meine das ist bei diesen reden von
amerikanischen präsidenten natürlich
auch immer der ganz spezielle situation
wenn präsidenten irgendwo auftreten dann
muss das publikum zwei bis drei stunden
vorher bereits anwesend sein es gibt
umfangreiche sicherheits checks und die
leute die sie dort sehen die sitzen
damit sicherheit schon zwei bis drei
stunden und warten und harren aus und
sie sehen die sonne senkt sich langsam
das heißt die haben da ziemlich das
gegenlicht das muss nicht immer sehr
angenehm sein als präsident obama zu
seinem abschluss besuch nach berlin kam
war es ein sehr heißer tag und wir haben
menschen haben dort zwei oder drei
stunden lang ausgeharrt in der
sommerhitze in zwei minuten höre ich
übrigens gerade kommt beiden da zwei
minuten reichen dass man auch noch mal
mit thomas jäger spricht da muss ich
jetzt nicht zwei minuten überbrücken
thomas jäger der politikwissenschaftler
noch einmal ganz kurz
sie haben es ja selber auch erlebt
besucher von amerikanischen präsidenten
und das ganze bohei dass da passiert es
ist ja oft so dass das schon ein
bisschen übertrieben erscheint was
würden sie sagen ist es wirklich nötig
ist er dort in gefahr muss er dort auch
geschützt werden in genf jetzt gerade wo
er ist der amerikanische präsident wird
immer geschützt und man kann sich
vorstellen dass hier die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen seit tagen
vorbereitet werden dass irgendwo auf
dächern scharfschützen gegend dass man
genau den platz im blick hat den er
begeht sie haben ja schon darauf
hingewiesen und auch schon selbst erlebt
wie das ist wenn man einem
amerikanischen präsidenten zu hören
möchte
da sind die sicherheitsvorkehrungen
enorm groß es gibt niemanden der
geschützter ist was sie auch daran sehen
dass er immer mit zwei autos reißt zwei
identischen immer weiß nie in welchem
sitzt er dann jetzt gerade trend auch
das soll den den schutz erhöhen
und ob das nötig ist ja meine güte
solange nichts passiert ist es nicht
nötig aber es gab eben auch an
auf amerikanische präsidenten nehmen sie
ronald reagan und es gab schon eine
ganze reihe von politischen morden in
den vereinigten staaten etwa die beiden
kennedys der eine als präsident der
andere als aussichtsreicher
präsidentschaftskandidat also insofern
ist die gefahr möglicher weise in den
usa einem einem einem anschlag zum opfer
zu fallen größer als im ausland gehen
wir doch noch mal kurz auf die beiden
personen auf beiden und auf putin
diese pressekonferenz die wir eben
gesehen haben von putin
sie haben sehr schön beschrieben aber
was ja auch viel war das ist von anfang
an wirklich eine pressekonferenz war das
fragen gestellt wurden dass putin nicht
mit einer rede begonnen hat und waren
okay mehr als die hälfte der fragenden
waren aus russland von russischen medien
was glauben sie
war das ein bisschen gesteuert
inszeniert oder war das wirklich eine
ganz normale pressekonferenz
jede spontane aktion muss gut geplant
sein
so und jetzt lieber thomas jäger jede
spontane aktion muss gut geplant sein
und der auftritt von joe gut jetzt habe
ich mich ein
ich habe gerade das letzte treffen
dieser langen woche mit so vielen dingen
beendet es hat viele ist presseberichte
über dieses treffen gegeben aber das war
im grunde ganz normal
sie haben mich ja schon eine reihe von
jahren beobachtet und es gibt keinen
ersatz für echtes gespräch
wir teilen beide besitzen beispiellose
verantwortung für die beziehungen
zwischen unseren beiden staaten wir
brauchen stabile und berechenbare
kurz wir hungern wir müssen kooperieren
können im gegenseitigen und
beiderseitigen interessen sowie
differenzen haben da habe ich gesehen
putin deutlich gemacht weshalb ich sage
dass ich sage und tue was ich tue und
wie wir dann auf bestimmte aktion
reagieren die amerikanischen interessen
schaden
ich habe präsident putin gesagt meine
agenda ist nicht gegen russland oder
irgendjemanden sonst gerichtet ich habe
eine ergehen dafür das amerikanische
volk wir haben bei coop 19 unsere
wirtschaft wieder aufgebaut und zur
beziehung zu uns verbündeten und
freunden weltweit wieder in gang
gebracht und das amerikanische volk
geschützt und das ist meine aufgabe als
präsident der usa
kein us-präsident kann das amerikanische
volk hinter sich bringen das
amerikanische volk muss die
demokratischen werte verteidigen und für
alle grundfreiheiten eintreten
die alle menschen unserer meinung nach
haben das gehört zur dna unseres landes
die menschenrechte werden das habe ich
direkt immer auf dem tisch des hauses
nicht geht nicht darum gegen russland
vorzugehen wenn man dort die
menschenrechte verletzt und dann so sind
wir eben wie könnte ich präsident der
vereinigten staaten von amerika sein
oder etwas gegen die verletzung von
menschenrechten zu sagen das habe ich
ihm gesagt wir sind das produkt ein des
großen gedanken sie haben das schon oft
gehört und ich sage es immer wieder
was ist denn diese gedanken wir leiten
unsere rechte licht fahren regierung ab
wir haben diese rechte weil wir zu
geboren sind weil wir leben
wir haben rechte an eine regierung
abgetreten
das habe ich es in putin deutlich
gemacht und deshalb bringen wir unsere
sorgen wie zum beispiel in vallendar war
nie so zum ausdruck das habe ich
präsident putin deutlich gemacht wie
werden fragen der grund- und
menschenrechte immer wieder
thematisieren denn so sind wir
wir halten diese wahrheiten für
selbstverständlich dass alle menschen
gleich sein müssen
wir haben diesen bogen der
verpflichtungen die wir haben immer
weiter ausgedehnt immer mehr menschen
ein rätsel sind habe ich angesprochen
zwei zu unrecht inhaftiert amerikaner
ich habe den anderen wieder angesprochen
und die bedeutung der freien presse und
der freien rede der redefreiheit
deutlich gemacht wir werden in der
realität nicht beeinträchtigen lassen
auch nicht unsere demokratischen wahlen
und und dem strich habe ich mir gesagt
dass wir einige grundlegende regeln
haben an die sich alle halten müssen
es gibt ja auch gemeinsame interessen an
der zusam bereit für unsere völker für
das russische das amerikanische volk
aber auch im interesse und zum nutzen
der welt und ihrer sicherheit ein
bereich ist die strategische stabilität
ich bin oft gefragt worden was ich wohl
mit putin besprechen würde ich hatte
gesagt gut ich habe ein persönliches
gespräch und da bricht das zum ausdruck
was ich meine
es geht unter anderem um die frage der
strategischen stabilität wir brauchen
einen mechanismus um damit umzugehen
wir haben dirigiert die nächsten
schritte besprochen die unsere länder
bei den rüstungs kontrollmaßnahmen als
nächstes an halten wollen müssen
unbeabsichtigt und flickte vermeiden und
wir brauchen einen bilateralen
strategischen stabilitäts dirk bathen
sprach dafür dass unsere kreditexperten
titel martin sich zusammensetzen müssen
um an einem mechanismus zur arbeit wie
sie absorbieren kann das neue
gefährliche hoch entwickelte waffen
beherrscht werden die jetzt eingeführt
werden
die reaktionszeit muss hoch bleibende
mussten reagieren können es geht um die
funktionsweise dieser waffensysteme
ein weiteres thema ist die cyber
sicherheit
ich habe darüber gesprochen die den
vorschlag dass bestimmte freund wiege
für entscheidend den trabi tour tabu
sein müssen und nicht eingegriffen
werden
diese weise mit elektronischen mitteln
ich habe 16 verschiedene punkte genannt
die wirklich die entscheidende
infrastrukturen rahmen der amerikanische
gut darstellen vom energiesektor bis zu
untersagen wassersystem was aber
grundsätze müssten durch die praktisch
unterfütterten verantwortungsbewusster
länder wissen gegen kriminelle vorgehen
die erpressung betreibens elektronisch
auf ihrem jeweiligen staatsgebiet wir
haben also experten aus beiden ländern
beauftragt an spezifische vereinbarungen
zu arbeiten über die grenzen und das
vorgehen in konkreten einzelfällen die
aus anderen ländern kommen oder nein
unsere länder ihren ursprung haben es
gibt eine lange liste von anderen
beispielen wir einen drogen wird die
themen korridor in syrien damit allein
lebensmittel dort transportiert werden
können wo menschen verhungern können sie
müssen diesen korridor schaffen und er
liegt im interesse russlands und der
vereinigten staaten wir müssen dafür
sorgen außerdem dass der iran keine
kernwaffen bekommt wir haben vereinbart
daran zu arbeiten russland ist natürlich
genauso daran interessiert die gier wie
können sie davon glauben dass die arktis
ein bereich der kooperation keine
konfliktzone wird dadurch ein teil der
fest konferenz verfolgt und von der
notwendigkeit gesprochen wir brauchten
ein modus operandi um dafür zu sorgen
dass die eine freie zone darstellt ein
freies gebiet wie also verhindern können
dass zb auch terrorismus wieder sich in
afghanistan bereich macht das gehört
auch für diese thematik
russland will das auch nicht haben
locker tourismus in afghanistan es gibt
weitere
große herausforderungen beiden
unverbrüchlich verpflichtet der
souveränität und der territorialen
integrität der ukraine bereich des
marketings weiter zu machen ob der grund
lag dass minister übereinkommen
ich habe unter sorgen wegen eloros gegen
weißrussland vorgetragen er war anderer
meinung hat er andere perspektiven aber
sie haben sicherlich viele fragen ich
möchte also hiermit zum schluss kommen
es war wichtig ein persönliches gespräch
geführt zu haben damit keinen der
fehlvorstellung davon besteht was ich
mitteilen weiter ich habe das getan was
zu tode gekommen praktische
kooperationsbereiche für unsere starken
müssen damit wie sie gemeinsam mit der
essen fördern und der welt nutzen
bringen zweitens müssen wir direkt
kommunizieren und deutlich machen dass
die usa auf aktion reagieren die unsere
interessen oder die der verbündeten
gefährden ist drittens müssen wir die
prioritäten und werte unseres landes
klar zum ausdruck bringen
für mich ist das alles klar der weg
liegt klar vor mir
dieser ton des gesamten treffens von
wohl vier stunden war eigentlich gut
positioniert es hat keine schrillen
aspekte dabei gegeben
die waren verschiedener meinung in
vielen bereichen haben dort jeweils
gesagt aber das ist sei nichts in
überladener atmosphäre erfolg haben es
nicht übertrieben
wir sind ruhig geblieben und ich glaube
ich hoffe dass die vereinigten staaten
der welt in der woche jetzt deutlich
gemacht haben dass wir da sind bei
unseren verbündeten an der seite steht
dass wir uns weiter an unsere
verpflichtung halten wir die großen
aufgaben anzusehen vor dir unsere welt
steht und nun haben wir eine klare
grundlage dafür geschaffen wie wild
russland umgehen wollen und wie die
russisch amerikanischen beziehungen
tatsächlich gescheit wie soll es bleibt
noch viel arbeit zu tun das ist
natürlich allen klar viel müssen noch
angepackt werden bevor ich ihre fragen
entgegen nehmen noch etwas
es geht hierbei darum wie wir von hier
aus weiter machen
ich habe einen größeren teil der
pressekonferenz fern präsident putin
verfolgt er hat darauf hingewiesen dass
es um praktische direkte ganz
bodenständige entscheidungen sowie ein
ergebnis finden müssen aktiv werden das
im nächsten sechs monaten oder im
nächsten jahr ermitteln ob wir einen
strategischen dialog sind voll führen
können die werden das sehen wir werden
auch sehen ob wir alles verhandeln
können
von den häftlingen russischen
gefängnissen bis hin zu anderen
problematische tagen bekommt ihr eine
cyber sicherheit regelung hin können die
da für ordnung sorgen
die länder die am meisten schaden leiden
könnten sind die länder die wir sich
falsch verhalten
ich habe zum beispiel von diesem
erpressungsversuch gesprochen
was würden sie denn sagen wenn man sie
erpressen würde und die rohrleitungen
von ihren gasfeldern oder ölfeldern
blockieren würde
er war der meinung das ist natürlich
auch hier gefallen könnten das nicht tun
darf ist also einig ich habe eine liste
von leuten publik bekommen die jetzt
fragen haben wir schön es ist wärs ja
die amerikanischen geheimdienste haben
erklärt deutschland habe sich in die
beiden ritzen wahlkämpfe mitschüler
willens und in anderen bereichen die mit
depressionen eingemischt präsent hin
keine verantwortung übernommen
ihr vorgänger hat solche einmischungen
nicht unterbunden haben wollen
wie können sie denn verhindern dass so
etwas jetzt nicht mehr rasiert ob ich
das beenden kann
putin weiß jedenfalls dass ich tätig
werden würde wie beim letzten mal schon
da hatten wir deutlich gemacht dass wir
das einfach nicht mehr dulden würden mit
dem endergebnis dass die botschafter
abgezogen wurden wir haben einige
einrichtungen in den usa geschlossen man
kennt in russland die folgen
ich vermute sie meinen das ist alles
nicht so wichtig aber das ist für putin
und andere führende politiker schon
wichtig die weltweite glaubwürdigkeit
nimmt ab wenn sich jemand falsch verhält
das muss man deutlich machen wie werden
die usa von der übrigen welt gesehen
wenn wir uns direkt in die wahl in
anderen staaten einmischen wir leider
weiß was dann wäre wenn wir solche
aktivitäten betreiben würden wie er es
getan hat dann ist das etwas das den
status eines landes verschlechtert der
verzweifelt versuchte sich als weltmacht
zu halten
es geht nicht nur darum was ich tue
sondern es geht auch um darum was andere
in diesem fall russland tun
nach den internationalen normen da ist
angeblich kein preis zu zahlen
man ist dort nicht in der lage zu
diktieren was wirklich passiert was
andere staaten in diesem fall die
wichtigen usa davon halten folgen wir
haben gesagt wird wie viel von
menschenrechten gesprochen
was wäre denn wenn alexei navalny
sterben sollte ich habe ihm klar gemacht
dass die folgen dann verheerend wären
für russland ich komme zum einen punkt
von vorhin zurück
hört geschieht denn wohl wenn jemand
sagt das geht ja gar nicht gegen der
wahl nie oder was da alles erklärt hat
und dass die behandlung von rabbani zu
rationalisieren und wenn dann weil die
trotzdem im gefängnis sterben würde
da habe ich ihm deutlich gemacht das
wäre eine ganz wichtige sache
es ist in der tat wichtig wenn ein land
sich so verhält
es geht auch um die probleme mit dem
präsidenten von syrien
dort sind ja auch internationale normen
verletzt worden der chemiefirma vertrag
ist verletzt worden es geht um vertrauen
es geht um die fähigkeit andere nation
positiv zu beeinflussen
wollt ihr denn unsere volkswirtschaft
mit der russisch martin austauschen
wollen wieder tauschen wir haben auch
über handelt viel gesprochen
ich habe keine probleme mit geschäften
mit russland so lang dass nach weltweit
anerkannten normen erfolgt das kommt dem
russischen volk ja auch zu gut ich habe
damit keine probleme wie man dort aber
licht nach den internationalen normen
verfährt was sie dann wohl bei uns geht
das nicht durch auch bei anderen
nationen nicht da hat davon gar nicht
gesprochen dass man anderen ländern
entgegenkommen muss damit sie in
russland investieren sonst tun die das
mir nicht nicht müssen erst einmal
überzeugt sein dass verletzung dieser
art nicht passieren auch ein hausarrest
wie amerikanische geschäftsleute wäre da
nicht denkbar
in amerikanischen unternehmer
investieren wollen dann darf sich das
nicht passieren dann muss die ganze
dynamik sich dort ändern
bekanntlich geschäftsleute lassen sich
sonst dort nicht in moskau blicken
schauen sie mal außenpolitik gilt als
eine überragende fertigkeit die schwer
zu beherrschen ist derart geheimcode
das ist aber ganz einfach die logische
verlängerung persönliche beziehungen
entsprechend der menschlichen natur
man muss fast verstehen wenn man ein
land führt dass sich nicht nach
internationalen normen richtet und sie
diese normen aber brauchen da sind sie
irgendwie zurecht kommen damit sie auch
eventuelle nutzen daraus ziehen können
dann stehen sie da dann haben sie keine
befriedigende antwort zu geben
es geht nicht für eine invasion in
russland wo das war ja auch ein witz
gebieten damals aber meine allgemeine
aussage ist folgende die dinge sind
einfach kompliziert
im vorfeld dieses treffen ist viel davon
die rede gewesen dass wir nach kalter
krieg begonnen kette zwischen den beiden
ländern hat sich bei dem gespräch hätten
irgendetwas gezeigt ich glaube die sonne
wegen ein wenig zu warm nicht
zimmermann ja sie haben eine frage
glauben sie das kind von seiner
grundlegenden rolle als zerstörer
abgerückt ist der restriktive verhalten
zeigt hat der richter geändert und ich
haben ja auch in der liste entscheider
infrastruktureinrichtungen gegeben haben
sich deutlich gemacht was an strafe
drohen würde wenn er dagegen verstoßen
oder haben sie das im wagen gelassen
hatte ihn reagiert die zweite frage
vorziehen
ich habe immer deutlich gemacht dass wir
beachtlicher fähigkeiten besitzen er
weiß dass er weiß nicht genau was aber
wir können sehr viel wenn grundregeln
verletzt werden dann reagieren wir mit
cyber techniken das weiß er ich glaube
das letzte was er im augenblick sich
wünschen könnte wäre ein kalter krieg
ich habe rein rhetorisch gefragt
es gibt eine viele tausend kilometer und
eine grenze zu china
china macht weiter und will die größte
volkswirtschaft der welt mit dem
stärksten solitär werden mit sind in
einer wirtschaftlich schwierigen
situation
sie müssen dann aggressiver vorgehen
also irgendwie die wirtschaft zum blühen
bringen
und ich glaube eigentlich nicht dass er
einen kalten krieg mit den usa haben
will
ich glaube nicht dass das habe ich noch
gesagt ihre generation und meinte
gedacht für liegen zehn jahre
auseinander da kann man sich kumbaya
singen wie früher um art euch und liebt
das ist kein kuschelkurs ist sondern es
geht um unsere länder die nicht in einen
neuen kalten krieg ziehen dürfen und ich
glaube er hat das verstanden
das heißt nicht dass er einfach die
hände in den schoß legen sagt macht doch
was ihr wollt er hat immer noch seine
eigenen interessen
macht sich immer noch seine gedanken
über viele dinge er glaubt wohl dass wir
irgendwie weg haben wollen
die besorgnisse hat er noch aber ich
meine lichter dass die triebkraft ist
bei den beziehungen die er zu den usa
haben will gibt es einen besonderen
grund dafür dass sie sich nur drei
stunden getroffen haben statt vier oder
fünf stunden wie es geheißen hatte
präsent putin hat er gesagt ich habe
keine bedrohung gegeben keine
einschüchterung
sehen sie das auch so und haben sie
meinetwegen auch afghanistan sicher
truppenabzug angesprochen
ich kann auf alles mit ja antworten
das ist so relativ kurz ausgelaufen
das letzte mal als zwei
staatsoberhäupter zwei stunden zusammen
auge in auge bis in alle einzelheiten
nein das ist vermutlich ziemlich lange
fällt es gar nicht sein
wir haben dann später noch eine größere
gruppe hinzugezogenen experten
der außenminister war die ganze zeit
dabei der botschafter wir haben alle
dabei wir haben so viel angesprochen und
dann habt ihr auch beide zusammengefasst
was wir besprochen hatten linken sprach
dann auch darüber was wir erwartet
hatten
wir haben erörtert oder auch
verschiedene teilaspekte das war also
ein zweistündiges gespräch der erste mal
wir haben mir die augen geschaut und
fragten wir uns wie geht's weiter was
passiert nun
worauf können wir zurückblicken
sie wollte ich zurück blicken wir wollen
36 monate drauf schauen und dann sehen
hat das funktioniert was wir zu tun
uns versprochen haben sind wir näher
gekommen an eine wichtige verbesserung
der strategischen stabilität hat es
fortschritte gegeben
das beta test sein
dieser prüfung wird stellen müssen der
präsident und ich haben uns darauf
geeinigt das heißt nicht dass dann auch
schon alles automatisch so passiert ich
sage nur es gibt die allgemeine aussage
die aus gemeinde aus sicht vielmehr aus
verbesserte beziehungen
es steht 1 grundsätze und werte auf
taunus sich das ganze schützen
nein bedrohen hat es nicht gegeben
es sind keine drohungen ausgesprochen
worden da hatte meine mutter erwähnt und
andere leute auch noch im persönlichen
bereich und wir haben dann auch
allgemeine dinge gesprochen
ich kenne dich ja ich rede aus
persönlicher erfahrung nach dem motto
was ist wenn das passiert also keine
drogen sondern einfache fragen nicht
eine drohung der form wenn ihr das tut
dann tun sie das
er weiß wo ich stehe er braucht was wir
gemeinsam hinbekommen können und es geht
um verletzung der mechanischen
souveränität und was sie dann tun würden
solche dinge er hat auch nach
afghanistan gefragten hatte die hoffnung
zum ausdruck gebracht dass wir der
friedenskirche schaffen könnte
2 also bereit zu helfen bei afghanistans
kann das nach titel ihren nachbarn iran
er wollte auch helfen da die museen und
ich habe dann gesagt dass wir
veranlassen wollten um stabilität und
wirtschaftliche sicherheit und auch
physische sicherheit für die menschen in
syrien libyen zu ermöglichen
darüber haben wir also gesprochen
wir sind ich habe anscheinend keinen
geben dass damit der rentenrechtlichen
erpressungsversuchen auf elektronischen
titel und auch die arbeitsgruppen thema
der cyberangriffe was ist er macht ja es
geht also generell um zwei bereiche haid
wie kann man gegen erpressung dieser art
gegen kriminelle auf russischem gebiet
tun
dort hat man das wohl nicht gemacht und
hat dass man auch nicht vorgesehen euch
wie nun tätig werden das wird gesehen
müssen wir haben jedenfalls gesagt dass
wir etwas machen werden wenn
internationaler normen als mit
weißrussland verletzt werden hier bieten
sich tatsächlich chancen dass bedingt
sich bewegen wir haben dann in größeren
kreisen noch zusammengesessen und je gut
informierte leute dachten dann das
könnte vielleicht doch mal probleme
geben wird dieser elektronik und wenn ja
wenn da jemand in flotter wird etwas
jährige plant dann ist natürlich gleich
an öl verdenken ölpipelines da könnte
man vorgehen an die lebensader könnte
man das liegt im allgemeinen interesse
weil alle betroffen sein könnten dass
solche gruppen das handwerk gelegt wird
der präsident betonte auch noch den
menschenrechten gefragt worden
er hat dann gesagt gegenposition gehe
vor
weil der keine fünften januar wie in
washington russland erleben sollte und
black metal hatte auch noch zitiert die
rechte der schwarzen
meine antwort dafür dass wir haben
gesagt haben das ist ein lächerlicher
vergleich
das sind zwei paar schuhe beiden fall
haben wirkliche kriminelle das capitol
gestürmt polizisten getötet und sie
werden es rechenschaft gezogen werden
und das ist was anderes wenn jemand in
der hauptstadt marschiert und
demonstriert und sagt die wollen reden
dürfen und das und das möchten wir
anders haben das sind ganz andere
kriterien tv landete wir sind putin
hatte gesagt
ihre bemerkung zu dem wort er seinen
keller eigentlich zufrieden ja erst für
frieden mit meiner stellungnahme dazu
verpflichtet die mehr dazu sagen
glauben sie dass man ihm trauen kann man
über den weg trauen
es geht nicht um vertrauen es geht um
eigeninteresse und überprüfung
das muss verifiziert werden
ob das vertrauen gerechtfertigt ist so
ziemlich jeder mit dem ich eine
vereinbarung hinbekommen möchte im
treasury ganzen glück ist ihm sage ich
wenn ich ihnen vertrauen kann gibt es
keine probleme
es kommt darauf an was herauskommt
letzten endes ist in der unser
sprichwort radio free europe und radio
liberty auch angesprochen worden
[Musik]
sie wissen dass ihr gebet aufgeht und
die pressefreiheit und die probleme in
russland
die habe ich alle gearbeitet
sie sind jetzt aus der tische agenten
genannt worden und so eingestuft worden
in russland sie sind in russland im
wesentlichen unter druck und werte
weggedrängt
meine frage wäre dementsprechend nach
ihren gesprächen
wie sehr ist er denn daran interessiert
dass medien klima und russland zu
verbessern
ich würde es nicht so beschreiben meine
klima verletzungen
ich würde eher sagen wie viel interesse
hat er dafür den ruf russlands
aufzupolieren demokratische prinzipien
nicht verletzt werden ich kann das nicht
so bewerten
er will sicherlich den ruf aufbessern
gesellschaft verändern wer glaubt wohl
dass es um das recht der regierung dafür
das zu tun was es tun will
das ist ein ganz anderer ansatz ich habe
so ziemlich alles gelesen dass er
geschrieben hat welche reden gehalten
hat ich habe mich mit ihm vertraut
gemacht und habe auch eine reihe von
guten biografie gelesen und ich habe ihn
dementsprechend deutlich gemacht dass
russland eine chance hatte einen kurzen
leuchtenden augen blick nach gorbatschow
und nach dem einschneidenden wandel
hätte eine kroatische regierung aufbauen
können aber man ist gescheitert ein
wettrennen unter russischen
intellektuellen denn die richtige
regierungsform was sollte man wählen
das waren ja damals und putin hatte dann
raschen beschluss gefasst
russland ist immer eine wichtige
internationale nacht gewesen wenn es als
einheitlicher russischer start auf einer
bestimmten geologischen grundlagen
bestanden hat von den kommissaren über
die
und jene zeit bis hin zur heutigen zeit
und mir ist jedenfalls klar das habe ich
auch gesagt dass er sich wohl
entschieden hat russland eine großmacht
bleiben und da muss das russische volk
einzuleiten
unter der kontrolle der regierung nicht
unbedingt ideologisch sondern die
regierung muss das sagen habe ich das
meint er und diese entscheidung ist
gefallen nicht raten denn wie anders
hätte ausgehen können aber jedenfalls
hat sich russland so nicht auf eine
bewusst möchte halten können
beim heutigen gespräch haben twitter
auch etwas roten linien angeht eine
militärische reaktion genannt als
mögliche reaktion auf einen
erpressungsversuch mit elektronischen
mitteln
sie haben wir auch gesagt gut hin habe
keine seele hat ihn jetzt nach dieser
begegnung besser verstanden
ja danke für diese fragen über
militärische reaktionen haben wir nicht
gesprochen
um das zu beantworten wir geben keine
wirkliche grundlage für einen direkten
dialog und vor allem seine positive
heute russland und china das haben wir
alle gesagt sie hätten wahrscheinlich
mehr zeit und persönliche verbracht als
jede andere politische führer ist nun
vielleicht auch die zeit gekommen wo sie
ihn anrufe dass china sich der handel
eröffnet und gehört da steht hier mich
reine gefällt nicht um freundschaft
wollen die kinder irgendwie unter druck
setzen sie haben ja dass die lieben
community unterschrieben wonach china
sich öffnen sollte ich nur sagen man
solle sich bei ihnen nicht einmischen
was der titel jetzt die haltung der welt
china entwickelt sich china unternimmt
große anstrengungen
ich will weit zu positionieren und als
verantwortliche sich ausbreitende macht
man kämpft wirklich darum der welt zu
helfen auch bei coop neuerdings stoffen
man jetzt unter dem grossen versuche in
diese richtung
manche dinge braucht man ist die weste
völker nicht zu erklären man sieht die
ergebnisse
das versucht china wirklich bis zum
grund zu gehen
einiges haben wir ja doch gesagt in der
eu und die sieben gipfel und in der nato
wir sollten versuchen die welt
zusammenzuführen damit sie daran
arbeitet was die mechanismen sind mit
denen man die nächste pandemie
kurzzeitig erkennen kann damit wir dann
auch frühzeitig reagieren können es wird
zur nächsten party wie komm wir müssen
da etwas tun
das also war das fazit des
amerikanischen präsidenten nach der
begegnung mit dem russischen präsidenten
man hat selten gelegenheit beide staats
und regierungschefs hintereinander bei
gleicher gelegenheit so ausführlich zu
hören und ich würde gerne noch einmal
mit professor thomas jäger darüber
sprechen
man ist ja immer bei solchen
gelegenheiten auf der suche nach
konkreten ergebnissen was hat das denn
jetzt gebracht dieses treffen
nun gibt es tatsächlich mehrere
anmeldungen die ja hervorheben dass die
botschafter wieder zurückkehren auf ihre
posten würden sie sagen das ist ein
konkretes ergebnis das wirklich was
bringt oder ist das nur so ein bisschen
diplomatische kosmetik das ist
jedenfalls ein richtiger schritt aber
dafür hätte man dieses treffen sich
gefragt aber es gibt noch ein sehr
konkretes ergebnis wenn ich in beiden
präsidenten richtig zugehört habe und
das richtig verstanden habe dann hat man
sich darauf geeinigt dass jetzt aus dem
bürokratien heraus arbeitsgruppen zu
spezifischen themen gebildet werden
die und das hat präsident beiden jetzt
konkretisiert in den nächsten drei bis
sechs monaten ergebnisse vorlegen sollen
die dann ermöglichen zu sehen ob man
gebiete der zusammenarbeit
identifizieren kann und ob man in die
richtung geht die der russische
präsident als morgenröte des vertrauens
bezeichnet hat weil sie den beiden hat
den begriff vertrauen weg gewischt hat
gesagt es geht um eigeninteressen und
die kontrolle
das ganze das zeigt also auch schon ein
bisschen in welche richtung diese
arbeitsgruppen arbeiten sollen nämlich
sie sollen die gebiete identifizieren wo
es überschneidende interessen gibt wo
man also erst mal zusammenkommt und das
monitoring der verabredung wird dann
eine aufgabe sein die hier zu erfüllen
ist weil man sich eben nicht vertraut
und deshalb kontrollmechanismen dienen
der ebenenpalette war präsident biden
ein wenig breiter noch als präsident
putin hat aber dieselben schwerpunkte
gelegt und es ist sicher dass
rüstungskontrolle und cybersicherheit
wesentlicher schwerpunkt würde die
arbeit des state department des
russischen außenministeriums in den
nächsten monaten sind das heißt am ende
geht ja nun etwas hand in hand auf der
einen seite die diplomaten kehren an
ihre orte zurück und gleichzeitig
beginnt ein neuer dialog der aber eben
auch überprüft werden soll sie haben es
erwähnt dieses monitoring nach drei
monaten nach sechs monaten will man das
weiter verstärken ja aber das hieße doch
tatsächlich dass es ein sehr
erfreuliches ergebnis gibt das nämlich
beide länder wieder näher aufeinander
zugehen und sich austauschen und der
dialog wieder verstärkt wird und dieses
schweigen und diese gegenseitigen
schuldzuweisungen dadurch vielleicht
aufhören
ich würde sagen es ist ein halb schritt
darauf zu es ist jedenfalls nicht so wie
manche kommentatoren im vorfeld gesagt
haben ja man wird sich zu nichts einigen
aber man wird sich vielleicht einigen
die eskalationen nicht voranzutreiben
also das was man verhindert an
schlimmeren entwicklungen in der
nächsten zeit war ich schon ein gutes
ergebnis das kann ich hier nicht
herauslesen
aber ob man schon so weit ist diese
gebiete der zusammenarbeit identifiziert
zu haben
das zeigen eben die nächsten drei bis
sechs monate und da wird das konkrete
maßnahmen geben die man etwa mit blick
auf die verhandlungen über das nuklear
kommen mit dem iran 10
möglicherweise gibt es hinsichtlich
afghanistan wo er bis in den september
dass es nicht mehr so lange hin
der abzug vollständig erfolgt sein soll
dass man hier zur vereinbarung kommt
gemeinsam die sicherheit des landes vor
einem neuen terrorismus gewährleistet
möglicherweise wird eben die versorgung
der syrischen bevölkerung mit gütern ein
erster oder nix dabei weiß sein dass man
die ja zu gemeinsamen ergebnissen kommt
ich denke der amerikanische präsident
hat das sehr deutlich gemacht dass man
eine ganze reihe von fragen auf den
tisch gelegt hat und es jetzt darum geht
auszuloten wo kann man denn wirklich die
ersten schritte gehen wo kann man
wirklich pragmatische lösungen finden
die dann auch zeigen dass break passt
zusammen zu arbeiten
man kann auf die abreise das misstrauen
überwinden
und wenn nicht dann bleibt es eben
besteht und man kooperiert denn das war
ja etwas da ist doch galten ja nun
wirklich auf die unterschiedlichen
staatsphilosophie in russlands und der
usa eingegangen
wenn er sagte die regierung wird von der
bevölkerung völlig anders eingeschätzt
es gibt ein völlig anderes
staatsverständnis in die vereinigten
staaten sind weltmacht aus einer ganz
anderen kraft heraus als etwa russland
und wenn man diese grund tatsachen sich
gegenseitig zugesteht und das verhalten
vor diesem hintergrund interpretieren
eröffnet sich möglicherweise der ein
oder andere handlungsspielraum und das
china erwähnt wurde ist eben etwas was
die beiden direkt in verbindung gebracht
mit einer sich möglicherweise wandeln
wenn russischen interessen zu professor
thomas jäger vielen dank für dieses
fazit vielen dank für diese bilanz und
wir werden der späteren sendung der tag
ja noch weiter gelegenheit haben zu
sprechen
aber fürs erste jetzt kurz vor der
tagesschau erstmal vielen dank an sie ja
damit endet die übertragung des treff